THE ASSEMBLY INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
WHILE WE WAIT FOR A QUORUM OF
MEMBERS TO ARRIVE AND THEN TAKE
ROLE -- I THINK WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND PROCEED TO HEAR.
A COUPLE BILLS -- AND THEN WILL
VOTE ON THOSE BILLS ONCE WE HAVE
A QUORUM TO SWEAR EVERYONE'S
CLEAR.
WE ARE ALLOWED TO HEAR THE BILLS
WE JUST WON'T VOTE.
QUITE YET SO I THINK MISTER.
MR EVAN LOW IS OUR FIRST
[inaudible]
BILL.
IN THIS IS AB.
SIXTEEN OH TWO WELCOME MR LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- IT'S GOOD TO BE
HERE AGAIN AS I MENTIONED TO YOU
EARLIER IN MY FOR FIFTH YOU'RE
NOW I HADN'T BEEN. TO THIS
COMMITTEE HAD HAD THE PLEASURE
BUT I APPRECIATE BEING HERE AND
I WANT TO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFORD --
WORKING WITH US ON NOT ONLY THIS
BILL MANY OTHERS -- ONLY DURING
EASTER WEEKEND BUT I MANY HOURS
SPENT WHAT WE HOPE YOU'LL WANT
TO COME BACK.
WE EXPECT THE WILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- SO MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN ZERO TWO OF WHICH WOULD
PROHIBIT A NEW INSURANCE PRODUCT
WHICH SOME CALL.
MURDER INSURANCE FROM BEING SOLD
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN THE
NRA STARTED SELLING AN INSURANCE
POLICY CALLED KERRY GUARD.
AT COVERS CRIMINAL AND CIVIL
DEFENSE IS FOR GUN OWNERS.
WHO USE THEIR GUNS IN A SHOOTING
GENERALLY SPEAKING GUN OWNERS
CAN BE COVERED FOR LIABILITY
UNDER THEIR HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE
POLICIES?
HAVING SAID THAT THIS INSURANCE
GIVES OWNERS A FALSE SENSE OF
SECURITY ALLOWING THEM.
TO SHOOT FIRST WITHOUT WORRYING
ABOUT THE CONSEQUENCES -- SO
GONNA SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
SHOOT FIRST AND HAVE THEIR
CRIMINAL THE FEES COVERED.
ALSO WANT TO MAKE MENTION THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
AND THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
EAST ISSUED A CEASE AND DESIST
ORDER -- TO THE HONOR A FOR
MARKETING -- THIS INSURANCE
WITHOUT A LICENSE AND THIS WAS
PRESS RELEASE CAME OUT ON
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN WITH YOUR
PERMISSION MISTER CHAIR I HAVE A
FEW PROPS I MIGHT LIKE TO JUST
HIGHLIGHT TO THIS COMMITTEE.
SURE AND YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES
THAT YOU'RE CALLING OKAY.
GO AHEAD SIR GO AHEAD -- I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHTS -- TO YOU --
WITH RESPECT -- THE TYPE OF
INSURANCE -- THAT IS PROMOTED TO
WITH RESPECT TO WHAT WE WERE
REFERRING -- TO AND THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY FROM THE IRA THIS
GUY PROVIDE YOU THE BASIC
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO NAVIGATE
THE AFTERMATH.
OF A DEFENSE SHOOTING.
HOW MUCH SHOULD I SAY TO POLICE?
AM I GOING TO BE DETAINED --
THIS BOARD HERE.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO ESTABLISH FOR
POLICE THAT YOU WERE IN FEAR OF
YOUR LIFE.
AND THAT YOU DID.
WHAT YOU FELT WAS NECESSARY TO
NEUTRALIZE THE THREAT?
YOUR TO ESTABLISH YOUR DEFENSIVE
ROLE AND SO I THINK THIS FALSELY
GIVES AS THE SENSE THAT.
EACH SHOOT FIRST AND WE'RE ABOUT
THE CONSEQUENCES LATER.
AND AS YOU WELL KNOW AS AS
REFLECTED IN THE COMING OUT THIS --
A NUMBER OF OTHER STATES ALREADY
PREVENT SUCH TYPE OF INSURANCE --
SO AGAIN WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
WE HAVE.
A SENSE OF DUTY -- WITH
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERSHIP AND
WITH RESPECT TO ASKS FOR DRIVE
OUT.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
MISTER LOW.
AND AGAIN TO BE CLEAR -- WE
WON'T BE ABLE TO VOTE ON YOUR
BILL UNTIL WE HAVE A QUORUM.
AND AS A COMMITTEE CHAIR YOU
KNOW THAT HOW THAT WORKS MR LOW.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS -- ARE
THERE ANY PERSONS YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
ARE THERE ANY PERSON SHOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK AGAINST THIS BILL --
ARE WE CLOSE TO A QUORUM.
STILL ONE SHY OKAY WELL MISTER
LOW -- WILL BE VOTING VERY SOON
ON YOUR BILL -- THE CHAIR IS
RECOMMENDING A SUPPORT FOR YOUR
BILL.
AND I'VE -- I THINK THE I THINK
THE VIBES ARE PRETTY GOOD ON
THIS ONE THANK YOU SO WERE.
WE'LL LET YOU KNOW AS SOON AS WE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MR Là [inaudible]
WHO'S NEXT.
FIND AND SHE'S.
IN THE HOSPITAL RIGHT.
IS SET UP.
GOOD MORNING MR WORD.
AND I KNOW YOU'RE HERE -- TO
SPEAK TO MISS BURKE'S BILL -- I
THINK WE'LL WAIT FOR MISS BURKE
OF FOR IF.
IF THAT WORKS FOR YOU.
AND FOR THE REST OF THE MEN OF
THE COMMITTEE.
MR COOPER'S OFFERING TO PRESENT
IT DO YOU WANT TO DO THAT JOB.
OKAY SHE OKAY HAVE YOU.
HAVE YOU TALKED TO HER -- YOUR
BILL.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO
PRESENT HER BILL OKAY.
LET'S TO MISTER COOPER'S BILL
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THANKS FOR VOLUNTARY.
JIM THANK YOU THANK YOU WELL.
THIS IS AB.
THREE FOUR SIX MISTER JIM COOPER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AB THREE FORTY SIX CORRECT
EQUITY AN EXISTING LAW LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
POLICE OFFICERS RECEIVE.
RECEIVE A WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS UNDER LABOR CODE
SECTION FORTY FIFTY ANOTHER
SCHOOL POLICE OFFICERS DO NOT.
COLOR FOR TWO WAS FORTY FIFTY
TIME THIS TEMPORARY DISABILITY
BENEFIT PROVIDES POLICE OFFICERS
WITH UP TO A YEAR OF PAID LEAVE
CONSIDER INJURED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN YEAH FIVE
POINT 2% OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
REPORTED BEING THREATEN A BOY
WITH A WEAPON ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
IN THE SAME YEAR TWO THOUSAND
STUDENTS REMOVE FROM CAMPUSES
FOR AT LEAST ONE DAY
.
THIS BILL IS LIMóN SCOPE EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY TO THE BENEFIT TO US
AND THREE OTHER SCHOOL POLICE
OFFICERS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE -- ARE THE PERSONS HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF MR COOPER'S
BILL AGAIN THIS IS A AB.
THREE FORTY SIX DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES MISTER COOPER.
ARE THERE PERSONS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SPEAK AGAINST THIS BILL.
WELL MISTER COOPER I THINK WE
CAN WRAP IT UP IF YOU HAVE ANY
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
ON THIS BILL.
THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDING APPROVAL
OF THIS BILL.
IN MAY BE TO BE CLEAR OF FOR THE
FOR ALL THE PERSONS IN
ATTENDANCE I'M RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT POSITION UP ON EVERY
BILL ON THIS AGENDA.
TODAY SO IF ANYONE'S WONDERING --
THAT'S THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION TO THE COMMITTEE.
COURSE THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO.
MAY PART COMPANY -- ON
OCCASIONAL -- ON SOME OF THESE
BILLS BUT MY RECOMMENDATION IS
IS A YES ON EACH OF THESE BILLS
TODAY. ONE MORE CHANCE TO ASK
THE QUESTIONS IN WOULD YOU FOLKS
<c.magenta>IKE TO GO AHEAD AND AND SPEAK.</c>
ARE YOU ON THE SUPPORT SIDE OF
THE OPPOSE.
SUPPORT WE WOULD LIKE TO SAY
ANYTHING CERTAINLY.
GO AHEAD -- GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS
SHANE DISHMAN AND I AM A THE
FIRST VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION.
AND WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL.
I'M A POLICE OFFICER CURRENTLY
SERVING -- THE KERN HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN A BEEN A POLICE
OFFICER FOR THIRTY TWO YEARS.
THE INEQUITY IN CURRENT LAW
WHICH PROVIDES A LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT OFFICERS
WITH FORTY EIGHT FIFTY TIME
CANNOT BE RESOLVED THROUGH.
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
KERN HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
OFFICERS RECEIVED FORTY EIGHT
FIFTY TIME.
BUT IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
DISTRICT BROUGHT LABOR CODE
SECTION FORTY EIGHT FIFTEEN TO
THE BARGAINING TABLE.
AND TOOK THE BENEFIT AWAY
BECAUSE ONLY LA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS LISTED IN THE CODE.
IN AN EMERGENCY WITHOUT
HESITATION.
I WOULD RISK MY LIFE TO PROTECT
THE STUDENTS AND STAFF OF MY
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
BUT BECAUSE OF WHERE I WORK.
I WOULD NOT BE AFFORDED THE SAME
TEMPORARY DISABILITY BENEFIT AS
OTHER POLICE OFFICERS IF INJURED
IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
AB THREE FORTY SIX CORRECT
CORRECT THIS INEQUITY BY
PROVIDING THE SAME BENEFITS TO
ALL SCHOOL POLICE OFFICERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YU SIR.
AM J. MANY OTHER.
NO TESTIMONY ALRIGHT MANY PEOPLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ONE MORE
CHANCE TO ASK QUESTIONS.
AND I THINK WE'RE STILL ONE
SHORT OF A QUORUM MORE AWAY OKAY --
MINING MISTER COOLEY IS IS
NEARBY.
AND WE HAVE FOLKS IS SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT GO AHEAD SIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PERSONS IN IN SUPPORT.
ANY ONE MORE CHANCE FOR THOSE
WHO OPPOSE THIS.
ALL RIGHT WELL I THINK -- WELL
VOTE SOON MISTER COOPER SOON AS
WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL VOTE ON
THIS.
AND AGAIN THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION IS A SUPPORT
POSITION.
THANK YOU ALL [inaudible]
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION.
AND MISS BURKE IS HERE SO LET'S
PROCEED WITH MS BURKE'S BELL.
AND WE HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST STAR.
ON THIS BILL THIS IS A RARE.
THIS IS A RARITY.
A RARE MOMENT IN INSURANCE
[inaudible]
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
HISTORY [inaudible]
MISS [inaudible]
MS.
TRACKING I'M NOT TRYING TO
EMBARRASS YOU NOT BRIAN.
HEALTH IS NOW MADE IT NOW LAST
NIGHT THE ANY BEFORE MUSIC 454%
OF BILLS -- TO BRING IN ALL THIS
IS GOOD.
YEAH WALK UP MUSIC.
IT'S LIKE BASEBALL ERROR -- MS
BURKE'S BILL IS AB -- SEVEN
FORTY GO AHEAD MR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE
TODAY WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
I AND BEHALF OF THE CO AUTHORS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY LOVE
AND QUIRK TO PRESENT AB SEVEN
FORTY THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
CHANGE CATASTROPHE FIND.
NEARLY THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
FAMILIES HAVE LOST THEIR HOME
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
INSURANCE HAS PROVIDED RESOURCES
TO REBUILD AFTER THE DISASTERS
HAVE STRICKEN.
ACCORDING TO VICE PRESIDENT
UNDERWRITING AND OPERATIONS AT
THE FAIR PLAN THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF
CALIFORNIANS SEEKING INSURANCE
COVERAGE WOULD BE A FAIR PLAN.
IN FACT IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS
THE NUMBER OF RESIDENTS COVERED
BY FAIR PAM PAPA BEAR PLAN
POLICIES IN THE WILDLIFE URBAN
INTERFACE HAS GROWN BY 35%.
AND THAT WAS BEFORE THE LAST TWO
COULD HAVE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES.
THE FAIR PLAN DOES NOT HAVE THE
NUMBERS FOR THIS YEAR BUT IN
SOME HIGHER IS COUNTIES THEY'RE
RUNNING 3100% AHEAD OF LAST YEAR.
AND ALTHOUGH FAIR PLAN IS AN
INSURANCE POOL ESTABLISHED BY
INSURANCE CODE IN STATUTE MOST
INDIVIDUALS ON FAIR PLAN PAY
HIGHER RATES AND ARE TYPICALLY
UNDER INSURED.
EXACERBATING THE HARDSHIP OF
WELFARE VICTIMS IS THE FACT THAT
CATASTROPHIC RELATED WILDFIRE
LAWSUITS CAN LAST BETWEEN SEVEN
AND NINE YEARS.
AND THE CONSTRUCTION DEMAND AND
PRICING SEARCHES ARE RENDERING
HOMEOWNERS UNDERINSURED BY NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
AFTER ENTIRE COMMUNITIES ARE
DESTROYED.
AB SEVEN FORTY AS A
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT WILDFIRE
INSURANCE AND UTILITY STABILITY.
THE GOAL OF THE FIND IS TO
PROTECT UTILITY RATE PAIRS FROM
INCURRING EXCESSIVE RATE
INCREASES AS A RESULT OF
CONTINUED WILDFIRE AND CLIMATE
CHANGE DISASTERS.
EXPEDITE VICTIMS AND INSURANCE
COVERAGE RECOVERY.
ENCOURAGE INSURANCE TO PROVIDE
IMPROVED QUALITY FAIR PLAN
OPTIONS AND WRAPAROUND POLICIES
AND WILL STILL HOLDING UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE ARE NOT THE FIRST STATE TO
UTILIZE A FINE TO DEAL WITH
CATASTROPHES SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY THREE FOR AS HAS UTILIZED
A SIMILAR MODEL WASHINGTON AND
OTHER STATES ARE CURRENTLY ALSO
EXPLORING FUNDS FOR WILDFIRES
AND OTHER CATASTROPHES.
AS WE'RE ALL AWARE THE GOVERNOR
WRIST WRIST RELEASED HIS STRIKE
FORCE REPORT A WEEK AND A HALF
AGO.
WHICH DETAILED EFFORTS
CALIFORNIA MUST TAKE IN ORDER TO
RECOVER FROM CA TO CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES AND HOLD UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE WHILE ALSO
STABILIZING THEM TO MEET THE
ENERGY NEEDS OF CONSUMERS AND
THE ECONOMY. ONE SUCH CONCEPT
OUTLINED IS A FUND THAT WOULD
CREATE A BUFFER TO ABSORB A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF WILDFIRE
LIABILITY COSTS THAT POTENTIALLY
COULD OTHERWISE BE DIRECTLY
PASSED ON TO REPAIRS.
ADDITIONALLY THE STRIKE FORCE
RECOMMENDED THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AND THE
GOVERNOR EXPLORE WHETHER OR NOT
ENSURE SHOULD BE OBLIGATED. TO
OFFER CONSUMERS WERE IN ELIGIBLE
FOR HOMEOWNER POLICIES EITHER A
DIFFERENCE IN CONDITION OUR
PREMISES LIABILITY POLICIES AS
COMPLEMENTARY COVERAGE FOR A
FAIR PLAN FIRE POLICY.
AB SEVEN FORTY IS BEING CRAFTED
IN A WAY THAT WAS FONT TO THESE
CHALLENGES.
VICTIMS AND THE STATE NEED TO BE
MADE WHOLE AND WE NEED TO DO
THIS EXPEDITIOUSLY.
WE NEED UTILITIES TO CONTINUE TO
MITIGATE A RECTIFY THE STANDING
IN CALIFORNIA WHILE RECOGNIZING
THAT WE ALL NEED TO PLAY A PART
IN THIS RECOVERY.
TRADITIONALLY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
SOCIALIZING THE COST OF WILD
FIRES WE THINK OF REPAIRS.
HOWEVER MOST AGREE THAT THE
SOCIALIZATION ACOSTA MUST BE GO
BEYOND WHILE REPAIRS.
EVERY MAJOR STAKEHOLDER MUST
ALSO PLAY A PART IN THE SOLUTION
UTILITIES INSURANCE AND THE
STATE.
OUR GOAL WITH THIS BILL IS TO
WRITE A COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION
THAT ULTIMATELY PROVIDE
STABILITY NOT ONLY DO UTILITIES
BUT REPAIRS AS WELL AS WILD FIRE
VICTIMS.
THIS IS OUR CALL TO ACTION AND
THIS IS THE FIRST OF MANY
CONVERSATIONS AND DEBATES THAT
WE WON'T HAVE AMONGST OURSELVES
AND STAKEHOLDERS.
TOLD UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE WHILE
WORKING TO MAKE VICTIMS HALL.
AND TRYING NOT TO DO THIS ON THE
SOUL AT THE SOLE EXPENSIVE
REPAIRS.
THIS IS A DIRECT AND TIMELY
SOLUTION FOR THOSE IMPACTED BY
WILDFIRES.
FINALLY AB SEVEN FORTY ALSO ARE
SO RIGHT AUTHORIZES THE
COMMISSION TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND
THE USE OF THE FUND FOR OTHER
CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED
CATASTROPHES AS DEFINED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
WE WERE NOT PREPARED FOR THE
PASSED CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
LET'S NOT MAKE THAT MISTAKE
AGAIN WITH OTHER CLIMATE CHANGE
CATASTROPHES.
MEMBERS THE FACE OF THIS ISSUE
SHOULD BE THOSE OF THE VICTIMS.
THE GOAL FIRST AND FOREMOST OF
ANY WHILE FINE WILDFIRE FUND
SHOULD BE TO PROTECT ALL CURRENT
AND FUTURE VICTIMS NOT THE
UTILITIES.
STABILIZING UTILITIES SHOULD BE
THE BY PRODUCT OF WHAT EVER WE
DO.
I BELIEVE ONLY THEN CAN WE COME
UP WITH AN APPROPRIATE AND
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION ONE THAT
WE CAN ALL STAND BEHIND.
WITH THAT I TURN IT OVER TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT.
THANK YOU.
MISS BURKE AHEAD MISTER WOOD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE FOR ASKING
ME TO JOIN HER HERE TODAY AND WE
LEARNED A LOT IN THE AFTERMATH
OF THE TUBS FIRE WHICH WAS IN MY
DISTRICT UP.
ALSO MENDOCINO COUNTY FIRES
WE'VE HAD.
SOME THE LESSONS IN RETROSPECT
SEEM KIND OF OBVIOUS BUT FOR
THOSE OF US WHO'VE NEVER LIVED
TO AN EVENT LIKE THE TUBS FIRE.
THEY CAME AS A PRETTY RUDE
AWAKENING. FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
LIVE IN A NEIGHBORHOOD IN YOUR
HOME JUST YOUR HOME BURNS DOWN
IT'S RELATIVELY STRAIGHTFORWARD
TO DETERMINE HOW MUCH IT WILL
COST TO REBUILD.
DO YOU BUY INSURANCE FOR THAT
AMOUNT AND YOU MAY BE BY A
LITTLE BIT MORE IF THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES WILL ALLOW YOU TO DO
THAT AND THAT ISN'T ALWAYS THE
CASE YOU CAN ALWAYS GET WHAT YOU
REALLY NEED.
PERFECT YOUR HOUSE AND FIVE
THOUSAND OTHER HOUSES IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD BURNED DOWN ALL IN
ONE NIGHT.
THE COST OF YOU TO REBUILD YOUR
HOME LOOKS SIGNIFICANTLY
DIFFERENT.
IN MARCH OF LAST YEAR SIX MONTHS
AFTER THE TOP FIRE THE AVERAGE
COST OF CONSTRUCTION LABOR
MATERIALS INCREASED 30%.
THIS IS ON TOP OF THE INCREASED
COST TO DESIGN AND BUILD AND
PLAN YOUR HOME.
OVER THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF
I'VE MET WITH CONSTITUENTS HAVE
BEEN QUOTED MORE THAN A HUNDRED
AND 522100% OF THE ESTIMATE IS
PER SQUARE.
FOOT COST TO REBUILD ABOVE WHAT
WHAT WHAT THE NORMAL RATE WAS
BEFORE THE FIRE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WOULD
MAINTAIN THE RECOMMENDED LEVELS
OF INSURANCE BEFORE THE FIRE --
BUT BECAUSE THE SUDDEN DEMAND
FOR SUPPLIES AND LABOR MOST OF
WHICH WERE IN SHORT SUPPLY
ALREADY THE EFFECTIVELY BECAME
UNDERINSURED MEANT MEN MANY WAYS
GROSSLY UNDERINSURED OVERNIGHT.
I REALIZE IT'S AN INCREDIBLY
COMPLICATED ISSUE AND THERE'S A
LOT TO CONSIDER HERE BUT I
BELIEVE THE CONVERSATIONS WERE
HAVING AROUND -- A. B. SEVEN
FORTY OF NEEDED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY SO WE CAN CONTINUE WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME.
MY DISTRICT AND MANY OTHER
DISTRICTS NOW IN CALIFORNIA
SINCE THE FIRES ARE STARTING
OCTOBER SEVENTEENTH THANK YOU.
MR WOULD THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME. TO TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL -- YOU AND I HAVE HAD A
NUMBER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
IMPACTS.
IN YOUR DISTRICT AND I KNOW
YOU'RE VERY VERY HANDS ON IN
TERMS OF DEALING WITH BOTH
TODAY'S CHALLENGES AS WELL AS
ANTICIPATING CHALLENGES DOWN THE
ROAD AND MISS BURKE -- ALSO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING A THE BIG
PICTURE BIG IDEA BILL FORWARD
[inaudible]
AND THE CHAIR IS RECOMMENDING A
SUPPORT POSITION AND DO YOU HAVE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WILL BE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL.
LET'S LET'S GIVE FOLKS AN
OPPORTUNITY -- IS OR ANYONE HERE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
ARE THERE ANY PERSONS WISHING TO
SPEAK AGAINST THE BILL.
THERE DON'T APPEAR TO BE ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS QUESTIONS MR
MAYES AS QUESTION.
ON NOT QUESTION -- I JUST WANT
TO THAT IS SAFE IF WHEN WE GET
ESTABLISH A QUORUM I'D LIKE TO
BUILD MAKE A MOTION ON ON THIS --
THIS BILL -- BIKE TO FRIENDS --
DOCTOR WOULD WHO SERVE THEM AND
I DON'T WANT CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE I WITH ME AND THEN
WITH THE SOME OF OUR BURKE WE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME.
A LAST YEAR IN REGARDS TO TO
THESE ISSUES AND SHE SPENT AND
IT AND ACCEPT AMOUNT OF TIME NOT
JUST LAST YEAR BUT EVEN THIS
YEAR.
ON UNDERSTANDING THE CUP HOW
COMPLEX THIS ACTUALLY IS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT DENY.
I WANT TO SAY THAT MOST DON'T
REALIZE THAT THERE IS -- AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT AND I KNOW
THAT'S AN OVER USED TERM HERE
BUT THERE IS AN EXISTENTIA
THREAT THAT HAS TO BE HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED -- AND AND THEN WE'VE
GOT TO AS A LEGISLATURE -- AS
THE STATE GOVERNMENT I WORK
TOGETHER IN A BIPARTISAN WAY A
TO BE ABLE -- TO TO TO COME UP
WITH A REAL SOLUTION AND SO THIS
IS PART OF THE OVERALL
CONVERSATION I WAS YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR BROWN DID COME UP WITH --
HIS REPORT -- A FEW WEEKS AGO
AND THERE WAS -- NOT A WHOLE LOT
OF DETAILS -- IN IN THAT REPORT
AND SO IT IS GOING TO BE LEFT UP
TO US I THINK TO WORK THROUGH
ALL OF THAT AND SO I WANT TO
THINK.
ABOUT DOCTOR WOULD IT IS SUMMER
BURKE BOB AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER.
LET'S SO WE IF THEY APPEAR TO
HAVE A QUORUM LET'S TAKE ROLL
REAL QUICK SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND THEN.
GET YOUR BILL PASSED.
DALY HERE MAYES.
YOUR BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
CALDERON.
CHEN [inaudible] TO COOLEY.
COOPER.
FRAZIER [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
IN NINETEEN PERFORMED. FOR
PURPOSES OF THIS COMMITTEE --
MEANS YES.
YOUR MEANS HERE EXCUSE ME.
IT MEANS HERE AND YES
[inaudible]
THE BILL.
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND --
TO PASS THIS BILL MISTER FRAZIER
HAS A QUESTION OR COMMENT YEAH.
THANK YOU BOTH OF YOU FOR TAKING
ON THIS -- THIS -- THIS ISSUE
WITH SO AND SO OVERWHELMING I
KNOW -- ONE OF THE THINGS IT
SHOWS IN ESTABLISHING THE
COMMISSION -- I WOULD HOPE THAT
WE COULD INCLUDE.
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT WE DID --
ALLOCATING TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR TOWARDS THE
EFFORT.
WHICH IS FAR SHORT OF WHAT WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO.
YOU KNOW A BILLION OVER FIVE
YEARS I THINK THEY NEED TO BE A
STAKEHOLDER IN THIS SO THAT THEY
GET SKIN IN THE GAME.
BECAUSE EVERY EVERY TIME THAT WE
HAVE THESE WILDFIRES SUCH AS
BACK.
TO ZERO AND SO IF THERE
INVESTMENT IS MADE TO SUIT
THROUGH THERE DID YOU ARE UP
FUND OR WHATEVER IT IS.
THE MORE THEY'RE IN IN TUNE WITH
WHAT'S GOING ON THE BETTER OFF
WE ARE WITH THEIR INVESTMENT AND
I I WOULD HOPE THAT IT BACK TO
BE IN A MOMENT AND AND I'M
REALLY OPEN TO THAT WE DO HAVE
ON THE CURRENT BOARD AT CLIMATE
CHANGE EXPERTS SO I THINK.
THAT THAT WOULD BE IT.
PREGNANT I THINK I CAN.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THE COMMISSION.
MR VOEPEL.
JUST ON MY COLLEAGUES KNOW I
SPENT NINE YEARS IN THE UNITED
STATES NAVY WHEN SAILORS MUSTER
IN ON DECK IT'S CO.
GOOD GOOD MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU CHAIR I THINK WE ALL
AGREE THIS BILL IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS AS IT SHOULD BE THE
GOVERNOR'S STRIKE FORCE REPORT
WAS RELEASED LESS THAN TWO WEEKS
AGO.
IF YOU WORK TOWARDS A SOLUTION
IS TO ADDRESS THE COST OF THE
WILDFIRES IN THE IMPACT THE RATE
PAYERS I THINK IT'S CRITICAL
THAT THE ASSEMBLY BE A PART OF
PROCESS. ONE SIX WOMEN BURKE AND
DOCTOR WOULD FOR THEIR HARD WORK
AND LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
I KNOW SALIM NUMBER BURKE WILL
CONTINUE WORKING RESOLUTION THAT
WE CAN ALL SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS MISTER MAYES.
MADE A MOTION WAS THERE A SECOND
I THINK THERE WAS -- IT'S TIME
TO VOTE.
I'M AB SEVEN FORTY THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES.
MAYES I BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE CHAN [inaudible]
TWO CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER I'VE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I GIPSON.
GIPSON I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON GRAYSON OCT I CALM WATER
DEATH.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HI THE BILL HAS TEN VOTE.
ALRIGHT THAT BILL IS PASSED.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
AROUND.
WHO'S NEXT IN LINE -- RIGHT
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
COME ON WE CAN EITHER A VOTE ON
THE SUBCOMMITTEE ITEMS.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND LET'S GO
AHEAD AND ADDRESS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THIS MOTION AND SECOND.
TO PASSED THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
LET'S VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
CALDERON CALDERON AYE CHAN. TWO
RIGHT TO I COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER I FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I GIPSON.
GIPSON I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HI IT'S TEN VOTES.
CONSENT CALENDAR PASSES --
PREVIOUSLY OPERATING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE WE HEARD A MISTER
LOW'S BILL AB.
SIXTEEN OH TWO THERE'S A MOTION
AND SECOND.
TO APPROVE THAT BILL.
ARE THERE ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
ON THAT SUBJECT IF NOT WE'LL
VOTE ON THAT.
ONE AB -- SIXTEEN OH TO LOS BILL.
ITEM.
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN OH TWO AB SIXTY
NO TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS DALY
AYE DALY AYE MAYES [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
CALDERON.
CALDERON I CHEN.
CHIU OR CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOPER COOPER I FRAZIER.
MR COOLEY DOES THAT ALMOST EVERY
MEETING.
IT'S REALLY.
IT'S REALLY COOL ON ABC YOU KNOW
TO I YOU MIGHT IF YOU ****.
THIS IS WHAT YOU MIGHT NOT YEAH.
IT'S ROCKY.
IT IS TO LOW STILL [inaudible]
YEAH THE GIVE ASSENT.
GIVES THEM I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON FIVE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL NO. SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ONE
SEVEN TO ONE AND MR COOLEY ARE
YOU STILL.
YOU CAN THINK ABOUT IT UNTIL THE
MEETING IS ADJOURNED ACTUALLY.
ANA.
YOU WANT TO WALK OUTSIDE AND RE
ENTER THE ROOM.
OKAY OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
ALL RIGHTY -- THAT BILL IS -- IS
ON CALL ESSENTIALLY AND I WILL
DO MISTER COOPER'S BILL WHICH WE
PREVIOUSLY HEARD AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AB. THREE FORTY SIX
ITEM.
THREE AND WE NEED A MOTION.
OCEAN SECOND ON MISTER COOPER'S
BILL.
LET'S VOTE.
ON EIGHTY THREE FORTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS DALY AYE DALY
AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
CALDERON.
CALDERON I CHEN. TWO TO AYE
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER AYE GIPSON.
GIVE SAID I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I'D COME WATER DOES.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I TEN VOTE.
WHILE WE WAIT FOR MISS GONZALEZ
AND MISTER GRAY -- THERE ARE A
COUPLE BILLS BY OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISS COM LAUDED -- OF
YOU HAVE A A BILL AND YOU'RE
WELCOME 2% THAT NOW.
AND MR CHU HAS A BILL.
ONCE YOU GO AHEAD.
MISS COM WATER DOT IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE READY.
YOU WAITING FOR YOUR WITNESSES --
OKAY.
SHE WE ADDRESS SHE WAS DOCTOR
TODAY.
THAT WASN'T THAT WASN'T MY IDEA
SOMEBODY ELSE SUGGEST ACT.
YEAH.
WELCOME AND PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK.
THANK YOU WELL GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I AM HERE PRESENTING AB.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE CIVILIAN EMPLOYEES OF A
CITY COUNTY OR SPECIAL DISTRICT
WHO ARE EXPOSED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY. TO ACTIVE FIRES OR
PERCENTAGE CARCINOGENIC.
MATERIALS FROM FIREFIGHTING
OPERATIONS RECEIVE FULL MEDIA
AND DISABILITY COVERAGE IF THEY
DEVELOP CANCER THAT HAS BEEN
LINKED TO EXPOSURE TO FIRES
BASED ON THE CRITERIA
ESTABLISHED TO DETERMINE
FIREFIGHTERS ELIGIBILITY. FOR
PRESUMPTIVE COVERAGE IN THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR CODE.
THE CIVILIAN EMPLOYEES SERVE AND
COUNTY FIRE SERVICE OUTFITS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AS FIRE MECHANICS
FIRE EQUIPMENT MECHANICS AND
OTHER MECHANIC WORKERS.
I JUST WANT TO DEVIATE FROM MY
NOTES FOR A LITTLE BIT. TO SHARE
WITH YOU ALL MY EXPERIENCE IS --
MEETING FIRE PERSONNEL -- I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TOUR ONE OF
THE FACILITIES IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU WHAT I LEARNED IN WHAT I SAW.
THE FIRE EQUIPMENT THAT THE FIRE
PERSON NOW [inaudible]
MAINTAIN.
AN OPERATE.
AND KEEP IN.
THE FINE STANDING CONDITIONS SO
THAT OUR FIREFIGHTERS CAN GO OUT
INTO THE WORLD AND PROTECT
COMMUNITIES.
HOW PROPERTY AND OTHER PERSON
NOW?
IS REALLY CRITICAL -- AND THESE
FIRE PERSONNEL FACE GRAVE
HAZARDOUS DANGERS EVERY SINGLE
DAY THEY'RE WORKING ON TRUCKS.
THAT HAVE TUBES AND HOSES THAT
ARE FULL OF ASBESTOS THAT THEY
ARE TOUCHING IN DEALING WITH
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THEY ARE CLEANING EQUIPMENT.
THAT HAS BODY LEE FLUID AND
TISSUE ON THEM FROM THE FIRES
THAT THEY ARE GOING OUT WALL
FROM THE FIRES THAT FIREFIGHTERS
ARE GOING OUT -- TO FIGHT AND
THEN BRING THAT EQUIPMENT BACK
TO BE CLEAN WE KNOW THAT OUR
FIREFIGHTERS WHO SUPPORT -- WE
SUPPORT ALL THE TIME HAVE
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT ON THEIR
USING PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT THEY
HAVE PROTECTIVE GEAR THEY GO
THROUGH A DECONTAMINATION
PROCESS THESE THAT ARE FIRE
PERSONNEL DO NOT ENJOY IN FACT
WHEN THEY ARE TAKING CARE OF
THIS EQUIPMENT WHEN THEY'RE
TAKING CARE OF THE TRUCKS.
THEY'RE WEARING THEIR GENERAL
UNIFORMS ANY THEIR GLASSES OR
FACE MASKS THAT YOU CAN BUY AT
LOWES FOR A DOLLAR.
NINETY NINE IT IS UNREASONABLE.
TO ASSUME.
THAT THE HAZARDS THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO PROTECT OUR
FIREFIGHTERS FROM.
ARE GOING TO MAGICALLY NOT
IMPACT OUR FIRE PERSONNEL.
IN FACT OUR FIRE PERSONNEL
SUFFERED TWO DEATHS A YEAR.
FROM CANCER AND CANCER RELATED
DISEASES AS A RESULT OF THEIR
WORK AND BEING IN CLOSE CONTACT
WITH CARCINOGENS AND OTHER TOXIC
MATERIALS BECAUSE OF THE WORK
THAT THEY DO [inaudible]
I WAS.
INFORMED OF A STORY.
OF ONE OF THEIR COLLEAGUES RAY
ORTIZ WHO WAS A FIRE PERSONNEL
WORK THAT.
AND HAD DECIDED AFTER YEARS. TO
TAKE THE TESTS TO BECOME A
FIREFIGHTER.
AND ONLY THEN WHEN HE WAS
GETTING HIS TESTS WAS IT
REVEALED THAT HE HAD STAGE FOUR
CANCER.
FROM BEING IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
CARCINOGENS OVER THE COURSE OF
HIS WORK AS A FIRE PERSONNEL.
RAY OR TEASE DIED.
THE TWO GENTLEMEN.
WHO TOWARD THE FACILITY WITH ME
ARE CANCER SURVIVORS?
THERE CANCER SURVIVORS.
BECAUSE OF THE TOXINS THAT THEY
INGEST NOT BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
BUT BECAUSE IT'S THEIR JOB.
AND THEY'RE JUST ASKING FOR THE
SAME PROTECTIONS THAT ARE FIRE
PUT THAT OUR FIREFIGHTERS
RECEIVE.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
WHEN THE FIREMEN IN THE FIRE
WOMEN ARE COMING BACK FROM THEIR
WORK [inaudible]
THE RESIDUE.
OF THEIR PEROT SAYS THEM.
IS WHAT OUR FIRE PERSONNEL.
ARE CLEANING UP.
AND SO THIS BILL WILL JUST BRING
SOME I THINK VERY PRAGMATIC AND
SENSIBLE PROTECTIONS. TO THE
HEALTH IN THE SAFETY OF OUR FIRE
PERSONNEL WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO ALLOW MY TWO WITNESSES LOUISE
DEL SAID A FIRE EQUIPMENT
MECHANIC FROM LA COUNTY AND RUDY
TORRES A FLEET MECHANIC.
FROM MENLO PARK FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT TO SHARE THEIR STORIES.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS LOUISE THEY'LL SAY IT
AND I HAVE BEEN A FIRE EQUIPMENT
MECHANIC. FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS.
I'M ALSO EXTREMELY FORTUNATE TO
BE HERE AS I AM ONE OF THE
NINETEEN MEMBERS THAT WE KNOW
OFTEN ARE SIXTY MAN FIRE
MECHANIC UNIT WHO HAVE BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER OVER THE
PAST SEVENTEEN YEARS.
FARM MECHANICS PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE.
IN ENSURING THAT THE EQUIPMENT
USED BY FIREFIGHTERS IN OUR
LOCAL COUNTY SAN SPECIAL
DISTRICT A SERVICE.
MAINTAIN A NEVER READY TO
RESPOND TO THE GROWING NUMBER OF
WILDFIRES IN OUR STATE.
AS A FIRE EQUIPMENT MECHANIC I
SPENT MY DAY SERVICING THE RIGS
AND OTHER EQUIPMENT USED IN
ACTIVE FIRES.
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON FOR ME AND MY
COWORKERS TO SERVICE TRUCKS COME
IN AND JUST AFTER RETURNING FROM
ACT THE BLAZES COATED INSERT
ANOTHER THE BRIEF [inaudible]
IN FACT.
SOMETIMES WE SERVICE VEHICLES
AND EQUIPMENT THAT HAVE BEEN
BECAUSE THE HAVE RESPONDED TO
NUMEROUS FIRES AND THE SASTRAS
BEFORE THEY ARRIVE IN OUR
FACILITY.
AND ARE LITERALLY COVERED IN
PARTICULAR MATTER FROM EVERYONE
OF THOSE INCIDENTS.
I'D LIKE TO STRESS THAT I LOVE
MY JOB.
WE ALL OF OUR JOB.
IT ALLOWS FOR ME AND FOR US TO
PROVIDE.
FOR MY EXTRAORDINARY FAMILY.
MY WIFE PATTY AND MY KIDS.
I DEVELOP A BROTHERHOOD WITH THE
GUYS IN OUR UNIT.
AND I LOVE KNOWING THAT.
WHAT I DO HELP SAVE LIVES IN LA
COUNTY?
HONESTLY UNTIL JUNE FIRST TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE IDEA THAT
I COULD GET SICK FROM DOING WHAT
I LOVE WHILE ALWAYS A REAL
POSSIBILITY.
IN OUR UNIT AS WE'VE HAD AT
LEAST ONE DIAGNOSIS EVERY YEAR
SINCE I WAS HIRED.
WAS THE FURTHEST THING FROM MY
MIND.
ON THAT DATE JUNE FIRST TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THAT WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH COLON CANCER AT
THE AGE OF FORTY TWO AFTER
RECEIVING THE DIAGNOSIS MY
THOUGHTS IMMEDIATELY TURNED TO
MY FAMILY.
WHAT WILL MY WIFE THE WITHOUT ME
AROUND?
HOW DO I TELL MY DAUGHTER?
THAT THAT IT MIGHT NOT COME
AROUND. TO SEE HER CHRIS
MITCHELL.
HOW DO I TELL MY BOYS?
BUT I'M GONNA SEE HIM PLAY
FOOTBALL [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
BUT I ALSO STRUGGLE TO COME TO
TERMS WITH HOW.
THE BEST JOB I'VE EVER HAD
EXPOSED ME TO TOXIC CHEMICALS.
THAT LED TO MY CANCER DIAGNOSIS.
MY THOUGHTS SHIFTED TO THOSE
LONG HOURS SPENT WITH MY
BROTHERS IN OUR MECHANICS GARAGE
BREEDING IN THE DIESEL FUMES
WITH IMPROPER VENTILATION.
SERVICING TRUCKS COVERED IN SOOT
FROM WHO KNOWS HOW MANY
EMERGENCY CALLS.
HAVING COMPARTMENT STRIP ON LOAN
FLUIDS ON ME OR ON US DURING
REPAIRS WITH NO STANDARD ISSUE
PROTECTIVE GEAR.
ONLY LIKE THE GLOVE SOME
PAINTERS MASS.
WHEN THEY ARE AVAILABLE?
WORKING ON FIRELINES WITH
FIREFIGHTERS TO MAINTAIN AND
REPAIR THEIR EQUIPMENT.
WITHOUT THEIR STAND THE
PROTECTIVE GEAR AND BREATHING
APPARATUS TO MINIMIZE THE
EXPOSURE TO CANCER CAUSING
AGENTS IN THE SMOKE.
WE OFTEN THINK OF OF OF THE
SMOKE FROM ACTIVE FIRES AS
CANCER CAUSING AGENTS.
BUT A TWO THOUSAND SIX META
ANALYSIS OF THIRTY TWO CANCER
STUDIES BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CINCINNATI COLLEGE OF MEDICINE
SPECIFICALLY HIGHLIGHTED THE
DANGERS OF THEIR MONTHS OUR
ABSORPTION.
OR TOXINS ARE ABSORBED THROUGH
THE SKIN.
THIS IS A UNIQUE REYES FOR US AS
MAINTENANCE EMPLOYEES WHO WORK
EVERYDAY WITH OUR HANDS WITHOUT
THE PROTECTIVE GEAR AND THE
CONTAMINATION PROTOCOLS ASSIGNED
TO OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN
THE FIRE SERVICE.
ON TV YOU SEE FIREFIGHTERS FIRE
ENGINES LADDER TRUCKS
FIREFIGHTING HELICOPTERS
PARAMEDIC SQUADS AND PATROLS BUT
WHAT YOU DON'T SEE.
IS ALL THE OTHER PEOPLE.
IN THE BACKGROUND LIKE US
[inaudible]
HELPING. TO MAKE IT ALL HAPPEN.
WHAT YOU ALSO DON'T SEE ON TV IS
THAT WE ALSO GET EXPOSED TO THE
SAME CARCINOGEN AND?
CARCINOGENS WHILE DOING OUR JOB
TO HELP SAVE LIVES AND PROPERTY.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE FOR ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER DEL CID AND
THERE'S ONE ADDITIONAL WITNESS
GO AHEAD SIR.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S REALLY TORE AS I'M HERE
IS A MEMBER OF ASKED ME COUNCIL
FIFTY SEVEN IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
I WORK IN A PARK FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT AS A FARMER CAN'T FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS.
IN MY DAILY ACTIVITIES AT WORK
THERE ARE TWO OF US IN THE
GARAGE.
WE'RE WE'RE EXPOSED ALL SMELLS
CHEMICALS A COME BACK FROM THE
FIRES WERE REPAIRING MAINTAINING
FIRE ENGINES AND EQUIPMENT USED
ON THESE FIRES.
WE'RE TOUCHING IT WE'RE
BREATHING IT.
WHEN SHE COMES BACK FROM FIRE IT
CAN BE OFF GASSING FOR WEEKS
MEANING THAT GARAGE SMELLS LIKE
AN ACTIVE FIRE?
WE HAVE ONE HEAVY RESCUE SEVEN
FRONT LINE OF FIRE ENGINES THREE
RESERVES THREE LADDER TRUCKS
OVER FIRE PER OVER THIRTY FIVE
PERSONAL VEHICLES A WATER RESCUE
EQUIPMENT FEMA EQUIPMENT -- YES
EQUIPMENT TO REPAIR AND MAINTAIN
IT AT ALL TIMES.
WE'RE ON CALL TWENTY FOUR HOURS
A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK AND AT
TIMES ALSO GET SENT OUT TO
ACTIVE FIRES.
ON THE FIRE LINE I'M EXPOSED TO
HARMFUL CHEMICALS IMPERIALS MUCH
IN THE SAME WAY MY FIREFIGHTER
COLLEAGUES ARE.
THERE BEEN CASES WHEN THE FIRE
ENGINE HAS BEEN PUMPING SO MUCH
WATER FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF
TIME THAT I MASTER WITH DONNING
MY TURNOUT GEAR AND ENTERING A
HOT ZONE TO REVEAL AN ENGINE
WHILE FIREFIGHTERS ARE FIGHTING
THE FIRE.
AT THE SAN BRUNO FIRE EXPLOSION.
I WAS FUELING ENGINES REPAIRING --
ENGINES SOME THAT WOULD NOT
START AND THEN WAS TASKED WITH
PUMPING WATER OUT OF THE HOLE AT
THE SEVERAL FIRE EXPLOSION.
THAT THE IT BLEW OUT OF THE
GROUND. TO HELP SECURE THE WATER
MAINS GAS LINE RATE MAINS ISSUE
SEWER LINE MAINS -- THIS CAN ALL
BE SEEN ON GOOGLE IMAGES OF THE
DISASTER -- THERE'S A BLUE POP
IN A RED TRUCK AND I'M I'M THE
ONE PUMP THE WATER OUT OF THAT
EXPLOSION.
I WORKED A FULL TEN HOUR WORK
DAY AND ONCE THIS BATCH THAT
WORKED ANOTHER NINETEEN HOURS
STRAIGHT AT THAT FIRE.
I WAS DEPLOYED TO ANGELS
CAMPFIRE TO RETRIEVE A BROKEN
FIRE ENGINE I HAD DONE FOLD.
TURNOUT GEAR BEFORE AIRING THIS
HOT STONE PREPARE THE FIRE
ENGINE AND DROVE BACK TO STATION.
THIS IS JUST A SMALL HISTORY OF
DISASTERS AND FIRES THAT I'VE
BEEN EXPOSED IN MY CAREER AND
SHOWS THAT OUR EXPOSURE IS A CAN
TO ACT THE FIREFIGHTERS.
I ALSO HAVE MY MEDICAL HISTORY
WAS IN TWENTY TEN WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH TESTICULAR CANCER.
AND HAD ONE REMOVED FOLLOWING
THAT HAD BLOOD WORK IN CT SCANS
FROM CHEST UNEASE EVERY SIX
MONTHS.
THEN IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THEY
SAID MY CANCER MARKERS START
GOING UP AND THAT SHOULD
CONSIDER GOING TO THROUGH CHEMO.
TO KILL THE CELLS BEFORE THEY
SPREAD SO I DID.
I WENT THROUGH CHEMO EIGHT HOURS
A DAY FIVE DAYS A WEEK FOR FOUR
MONTHS.
CAME -- BECAME MY FULL TIME JOB
FOR FOUR MONTHS.
THEY HAVE WATCH ME FOR FIVE
YEARS AND THANKFULLY MY MARKERS
HAVE STAYED NORMAL.
DURING MY TREATMENT THANKFULLY I
HAD MEDICAL COVERAGE THROUGH MY
EMPLOYER I USED ALL MY EARNED
SICK LEAVE MY VACATION LEAVE --
DONATED LEAVE FROM CO WORKERS
AND THEN TRANSITION ON THE STATE
DISABILITY.
THE FINANCIAL UNCERTAINTY OF
MEDICAL CRISIS IS DIFFICULT ON
ITS OWN LET ALONE TRYING TO
FIGHT FOCUS ON GETTING BETTER.
I LOVE MY JOB.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
RISKS THAT COME WITH IT
FIREFIGHTERS ARE TWICE AS LIKELY
AS THE GENERAL PUBLIC TO BE
DIAGNOSED WITH TESTICULAR CANCER
AND MY JOB I AM ALSO EXPOSED TO
MUCH OF THE SAME STUFF BOTH IN
THE GARAGE AND WHEN DEPLOYED.
HAVING SIMILAR.
WORKERS COMPENSATION BENEFITS
AVAILABLE TO ME AND MY FAMILY
ONLY SEEMS TO BE FAIR.
I WOULD HELP ALLEVIATE SOME OF
THE WORRY THAT COMES WITH A RISK
EXPOSURE.
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER TAURUS.
AND UP I THINK A COUPLE OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS MISTER CHIU.
OF MISTER GRAYSON LET'S HEAR
FROM SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO COMMITTEE
COMMENTS WE'LL HEAR FROM
SUPPORTERS AS WELL AS ANY
OPPONENTS OTHER PERSONS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING THIS CHAIR MASSAGER
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HARRY WONG.
I'M ALSO PRESIDENT OF ASKED ME
LOCAL.
ONE NINETEEN OR FOR LOSS SAID
JUST COUNTY FIRE.
BY MECHANICS.
ABILIFY MECHANIC. FOR THE COUNTY
OF LOS AS A FOR SIXTEEN YEARS
AND AS A CANCER SURVIVOR.
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JERRY TORRE IS.
I LIVE IN RHODE CITY AMMON
SUPPORT OF BILL AB.
FOR TEN HUNDRED ALL RIGHT THANKS
JIMMY.
MITCH SNIDER CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
AUDIBLE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANDY YOUNG I'M
HELICOPTER MECHANIC FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT.
NEST IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GARY HAJJ LA COUNTY FARM
MECHANIC AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
EVERITT BURGERS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FIREFIGHTERS
ASSOCIATION AN ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTS THE ENTIRE ASPECT OF
THE FIRE SERVICE CAREER UNION.
VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTERS AND THE
FIVE YEAR FIREFIGHTER SEASONAL I
CAN TELL YOU THAT.
WHAT THESE PEOPLE ARE SAYING IS
EXACT INTEREST NAY DESERVE THE
SAME PROTECTION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL PERSONS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
ARE THERE ANY PERSONS WISHING TO
SPEAK AGAINST THIS BILL.
PLEASE GO AHEAD
.
GO AHEAD ANNA.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS STATE POOR JUST ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY IS HERE TODAY AND VERY
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION OF AB.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM IS A
NO FAULT SYSTEM DESIGNED TO
FAVOR ANY WORKER WHO CLAIMS THAT
INJURY OR ILLNESS IS WORK
RELATED.
LABOR CODE SECTION THIRTY TWO OH
TWO REQUIRES THAT CALIFORNIA
WORKERS COMPENSATION STATUTES
QUOTE SHALL BE LIBERALLY
CONSTRUED BY THE COURTS WITH THE
PURPOSE OF EXTENDING THEIR
BENEFITS FOR THE PROTECTION.
OF PERSONS INJURED IN THE COURSE
OF THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
THE CALIFORNIA WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM PROVIDES
GENEROUS BENEFITS TO
FIREFIGHTERS WHO WERE DIAGNOSED
WITH CANCER.
MEDICAL EVIDENCE IS LINKED
EXCESSIVE EXPOSURE TO
CARCINOGENS WITH CANCER SO
FIREFIGHTERS DO NOT NEED TO
DEMONSTRATE WORK CAUSATION FOR
RELATED WORK COMPENSATION
BENEFITS.
INSTEAD THESE INJURIES AND
ILLNESSES ARE PRESUMED UNDER
THEIR WORK TO BE RELATED TO THE
EXPOSURE THAT THEY HAVE FIGHTING
A FIRE FIGHTER OPERATIONS.
SINCE THESE INJURIES ARE
PRESUMED TO BE INDUSTRIAL
COMPENSATION AWARDED FOR THESE
INJURIES INCLUDES FULL HOSPITAL
SURGICAL MEDICAL TREATMENT
DISABILITY INDEMNITY PAYMENTS
AND DEATH BENEFITS.
AN EXISTING LAW SPECIFICALLY
EXCLUDES ADMINISTRATIVE
PERSONNEL FROM THE PRESUMPTION
THAT CANCER IS INDUSTRIAL
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT EXPOSED TO
THE RISK OF ENGAGING AND FIRE
SUPPRESSION RESCUE OR THE
PROTECTION OF LIFE AND PROPERTY.
BECAUSE AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
EXPANDS THE QUALIFICATIONS OF
CANCER PRESUMPTION BENEFITS FROM
FIREFIGHTERS.
TO AN UNCLEAR FIRE SERVICE
PERSONNEL WITHOUT CLEARLY
DEFINING THE CLASSIFICATIONS
THIS INCLUDES.
THIS WOULD GRANT PRESUMPTIONS TO
NON PUBLIC SAFETY POSITIONS THAT
ARE NOT EXPOSED TO THE SAME.
SAFETY OR HEALTH HAZARDS.
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO PARTNER
WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE
ON A BROADER CONVERSATION ABOUT
PRESUMPTION ELIGIBILITY THAT
EXAMINE STRONG PREVENTATIVE
SAFETY MEASURES AND THE COST IN
IMPACTS THAT SUCH CHANGES WOULD
HAVE ON OUR INJURED WORKERS AND
ON LOCAL BUDGETS PRIOR TO
FURTHER EXPANSION.
HOWEVER AT THIS TIME WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD SIR.
JOSH DUGGAR REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES JUST LIKE TO ECHO THE
CONCERNS OF THE ASSOCIATION
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES -- WHAT
WE TRULY APPRECIATE THE BRAVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO RISK THEIR
HEALTH AND SAFETY FIGHTING FIRES
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS
LEGISLATION?
ON THE EXISTING PRESUMPTIONS
WERE DELIBERATELY AND NARROWLY
CRAFTED FOR ONLY THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE EVIDENCE IS
CLEAR AND CONVINCING THAT IT'S
GOING.
TO WORK ACTIVITIES -- IT'S
UNCLEAR WHY THE EXISTING WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM IS
INSUFFICIENT OR INADEQUATE AND
COVERING CASES WHERE THERE IS
CLEAR AND CONVINCING WHERE IT IS
CLEAR AND CONVINCING THAT THE
ILLNESS OR INJURY IS PROVED TO
BE CAUSED BY THE WORK ACTIVITY.
MEANING IT DOESN'T IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE A PRESUMPTION TO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL CLAIM OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION.
FINALLY WHILE WE WHILE IT IS A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THIS
PRESUMPTION WOULD RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT INVESTIGATIVE DUTIES
OF FOUR OR AND POTENTIAL
EXPOSURE TO CIVIL LIABILITY FOR
LOCAL.
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYERS AND
POTENTIAL MISUSES OF A PUBLIC
FUNDS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD THE WESTERN MEMBERS AT
JASON FALTER HERE ABOUT HALF OF
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND SSDI SACK
ACCESS INSURANCE AUTHORITY -- IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED [inaudible]
COOL.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER PERSONS
WISHING TO SPEAK AGAINST THIS
BILL.
IF NOT OF MISS.
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU TO SUMMARIZE
AND ALSO -- ADDRESS THE
AMENDMENT LANGUAGE THAT -- WE
HAVE DISCUSSED.
IF YOU DO THAT I WILL LET RYAN
ALISON ADDRESS -- THE RESPONSES
TO THE OPPOSITION AND HAVE A
QUOTE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH BOB
O'BRIEN OFTEN BEHALF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES OF
SPONSORED BILL.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE INITIAL
DRAFT -- WAS FAR TOO BROAD -- WE
ARE AGREED WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK -- FOR THE
REMARKABLE ANALYSIS -- WE WE
AGREED TO TAKE A MOMENTOUS THAT
ENSURE THAT WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT DESK EMPLOYEES OR EMPLOYEE
TO DO NOT HAVE EXPOSURE TO
ACTIVE.
THE HEALTH HAZARDS OF FIRES
RESULT AND OR OR RESULTING FROM
ACTIVE FIRES OF THE POINT IS.
TO INSURE THAT WE ARE CRAP
CRAFTING A VERY TIGHT CIRCLE
AROUND EMPLOYEES OR WITH
SPECIFIC EXPOSURE WE INTENDED --
AND AND WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS REFERENCED IN THE
ANALYSIS ARE THAT WE ARE --
TAKING AMENDMENTS MOVING OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO CLARIFY THAT.
AND I WOULD JUST CLOSE BY SAYING --
THAT THIS FLEET THAT I VISITED.
CALLED ON FIFTY RESEARCHERS TO
CALM.
AND STUDY THE CLIMATE THE WORK
CLIMATE. TO GIVE THEM ADDITIONAL
DATA ON THE HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS
UNDER WHICH THEY WORK.
AND FIFTY RESEARCHERS.
THROUGH THEIR SUPERVISORS
DECLINED TO COME TO VISIT THE
FACILITIES BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
LEVEL OF CARCINOGENS AND TOXINS
AND IF THAT DOESN'T TELL YOU
SOMETHING ABOUT THE WORK
CONDITIONS OF THESE WORKERS THEN
I DON'T KNOW WHAT DOES.
AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED WOULD HAVE
THE PRACTICAL EFFECT OF
EXTENDING FULL MEDICAL DEATH AND
DISABILITY COVERAGE TO SPECIFIC
WORKERS WITH CANCER DIAGNOSES
RESULTING FROM DUTY EXPERIENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SO -- WHERE THINGS STAND IS THE
CHAIR IS RECOMMENDING SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL?
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN AGREED TO
AS DESCRIBED BY MISTER ALLISON
AND COMMITTED TO BY MISS CALM
WATER DOVE -- I THINK IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR THAT THE WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE.
AND LET'S GIVE -- MISTER GRAYSON
OPPORTUNITY AND MISTER GIBSON
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND FIRST
I JUST WANT TO STATE -- THAT
THESE EMPLOYEES ARE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF WHAT MANY IN
SOCIETY LOOK TO OUR AS HEROES
AND THAT'S OUR FIREFIGHTERS.
BUT THEY WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO
THE JOB THEY DO AND ENJOY THE
STATUS OF A HERO IF IT WASN'T
FOR THE GOOD WORK OF THESE
EMPLOYEES THAT MAINTAIN THE
EQUIPMENT -- THAT FIREFIGHTERS
SHOES.
AND I ALSO WANT TO STATE THAT --
IT WAS MADE A COMMENT WAS MADE
ABOUT HOW FIREFIGHTERS HAVE THE
PROTECTIVE GEAR AND THESE
EMPLOYEES DON'T.
EVEN WITH THE PROTECTIVE GEAR
OUR FIREFIGHTERS ARE BECOMING --
VICTIMS AT A VERY HIGH RATE TO
CANCER BASED ON JOB RELATED
EXPOSURE SO WITH THAT -- I JUST
WANT TO ASK A QUESTION AND A
POINT WILL BE MADE OUT OF THIS
QUESTION -- WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A
FIREFIGHTER GOES -- TO SCENE AND
PUTS OUT A FIRE THEY COME BACK
TO THE STATION WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE FIREFIGHTERS CLOTHING ONCE
THEY ARRIVE BACK AT THE STATION
[inaudible]
SO -- TO MY MY MY UNDERSTANDING
MISTER GRAYSON IS THAT -- IT IS
RECOGNIZED THAT DOES -- MET
THOSE CLOTHES THAT CLOTHING --
CONTAINS A CARCINOGENIC
MATERIALS FROM THE FIRES -- AND
THOSE ARE CARCINOGENIC MATERIALS
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED -- BY --
THE CURRENT STATUTE BY THE
INTERNATIONAL AGENCY OF OUR
RESEARCH THAT ON CANCER HAS
IDENTIFIED AT A LIST OF ACTIVE
CARCINOGENS AND BECAUSE OF THAT
FIREFIGHTERS ARE REQUIRED. TO
DEPOSIT THEIR TURNOUT GEAR INTO --
BAGS THAT ARE OFTEN SHIPPED OFF
TO PRIVATE COMPANIES THAT
DISCARD OF THESE MATERIALS OF OF
APPROPRIATELY SO THEY'RE TREATED
IN A HAZARDOUS MATERIALS WAY
CORRECT.
FULL THE CONTAMINATION PROCESS
AND IN THEM THEIR UNIFORMS ARE
PUT INTO A VERY SECURE BACK AND
IMMEDIATELY TAKEN OFF.
SO THESE EMPLOYEES THAT ARE NOW
MAINTAINING THIS EQUIPMENT
THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT BACK FROM
THE SAME SCENE.
THAT THESE FIREFIGHTERS COME
BACK FROM WHOSE CLOTHING IS
CONSIDERED HAZARDOUS AT THIS
POINT.
THEY'RE EXPOSED TO THE SAME
CARCINOGENS WHAT HAPPENS TO
THEIR CLOTHING.
THEY'RE WEARING UNIFORMS THAT
YOU WOULD SEE YOUR MECHANIC HAVE
WHEN YOU TAKE YOUR CAR TO THE
AUTO BODY SHOP THEY ARE PUTTING
ON GLASSES THAT YOU CAN BUY AT
ANY -- HOME IMPROVEMENT STORE
THERE ARE WEARING MASKS THAT YOU
CAN BUY AT ANY PAINT STORE SO
THE FIREFIGHTERS CLOSE GET
SHIPPED OFF TO A HAZMAT PLACE.
THE MAINTENANCE WORKERS CLOSED
GOES HOME A GETS WASHED WITH THE
KIDS CLOTHES PRECISELY.
OKAY SO WITH THAT WHAT -- TO
WHAT WHAT IS THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL WHO ARE RECOVERING -- IS
FAR AS THE THE NUMBER OF IS A
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES OR IS THAT
EVERYBODY WHO LIAM WHO ARE
RECOVERING POTENTIALLY WHAT
WE'RE REFERRING TO A CIVILIAN.
EMPLOYEES WITH EXPOSURE AND AND
AND THAT WOULD IN OUR ESTIMATION
BE MECHANIC -- CLASSIFICATIONS
OF AND THESE ARE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES -- EMPLOYED BY CITIES
COUNTIES SPECIAL DISTRICTS HAVE
PERCENTAGE WISE COMPARED TO
FIREFIGHTERS WATER WHICH I WHAT
WHAT PERCENTAGE ARE WE TALKING A
BELIEVE IT'S ABOUT A THIRTY
THIRD. ONE RETURN ONE RATIO LOTS
OF THE FIREFIGHTERS TO MECHANICS
SO I HEARD THAT WOULD BE ABOUT A
ONE POINT 5%.
YEAH FIGURES THAT CORRECT IN
TERMS OF TOTAL COSTS THROUGH
SYSTEM WE ESTIMATE THAT -- THE
NUMBER IS LIKELY TO BE -- IN LA
COUNTY SPECIFICALLY WERE TALKING
122% OKAY -- SO YEAH THAT'S
CORRECT I THANK YOU.
HAPPENS IT HAPPENS A MISTER
GIBSON AND THEN MR CHIU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN --
MISTER GRAYSON AND TOOK A LOT OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT I WAS GOING
TO ASK BECAUSE I WAS GLAD TO
THOSE IT'S OKAY -- BUT THEY NEED
TO BE -- ASSN ADDRESS -- FIRST
WHAT'S GOING TO SAY I APPRECIATE
WHAT THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I APPRECIATE NOW
HER DURING OUR HOMEWORK BUT ALSO
GOING OUT. TO THE ACTUAL
FACILITIES AND IN DOING HER OWN
INVESTIGATION BEFORE SHE ACTS
OFF OF HIS BILL WHICH AGAIN
SHOWS ME SHE'S VERY VERY
THOROUGH AND THIS IS ALSO AN
ISSUE THIS IS THE ISSUE.
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE LEAVE NO ONE BEHIND AND I
THINK THIS BILL DOES JUST THAT --
AS MY COLLEAGUE WAS GRAYSON ALSO
INDICATED AN ILLUSTRATED -- THAT
THE SAME CARCINOGENS THAT
FIREFIGHTERS JUST YOU KNOW TAKE
OFF -- IS THE SAME ONES THAT
THESE MECHANICS GO IN AND USE
AND EXPOSE THEMSELVES -- TO ON A
DAILY BASIS AND SHOULD BE
COVERED UNDER WORKMAN'S COMP WE
APPRECIATE THOSE OF TESTIFIED --
WEPRAY YOUR HEALING -- SO THAT
YOU CAN CONTINUE TO GROW UP OF
WATCH OUR KIDS GROW UP AND SEE
THEM PLAY BASEBALL OR FOOTBALL
INTO ALL THE THINGS -- THAT A
FATHER -- EXPECT OF THEIR
CHILDREN AND ALSO -- HUSBAND AND
SO I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU OFFER
SHE WOULD PLEASE CONSIDER
INCLUDING ME AS A COUGH OF HIS
BILL -- AND I WOULD CERTAINLY
LOVE -- TO BE AT EVERY JUNCTURE --
TO HELP -- EVEN ON THE FLOOR OF
THE STATE ASSEMBLY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
[inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY.
MR CHIU GO AHEAD SIR.
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHARM OF FIRST OFF ALL THE
ONE THANK YOU ALSO FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD.
YOU KNOW WHEN I WAS ON SOUND THE
CITY COUNCIL I DID VISIT WE'LL
CALL THE OPERATION YARD WHICH
MANY OF THOSE -- A YOU COULD
MINTS ARE MAINTAINED AND SOON
AFTER RIGHT I READ THE BILL I
JUST REALLY FELT THAT THE
THERE'S A LOT OF IMPROVEMENT
SAFETY IMPROVE MY HEALTH.
IMPROVEMENT THAT WE CAN MADE --
TO TO TO TO THE OPERATION YOU
ARE IN THE WAY TO THE OPERATOR
SO -- AND ALSO I'M JUST HOPING
THAT THIS BILL WILL START A
BIGGER CONVERSATION OF HOW CAN
WE PREVENT.
YOU KNOW GOOD GOES TO A THINGS
TO HAPPEN LIKE REQUIRE.
ANYBODY TO GO TO A FIRE LINE.
TWO HOUSES CERTAIN PROTECTIVE
GEAR.
AND AND AND ALSO -- THE LEGACY
IMPROVE OPERATIONAL OPERATIONAL
YARD.
SO -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN
AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS
MOTION.
A MISTER MASON SKEWS ME MR MAYES
AS QUESTION THEN MISTER COOPER
WELL JUST A QUICK A QUICK
COMMENT -- I MAY BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL -- TODAY I AM
SYMPATHETIC. TO THE SLIPPERY
SLOPE ARGUMENT A BECAUSE WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR WORKERS
COMP -- A PROGRAM IS --
FINANCIALLY -- HEALTHY -- I DO
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU BROUGHT THIS
BILL FORD -- AND I THINK IT IS A
NECESSARY -- BILL WE JUST NEED
TO MAKE SURE -- THAT -- WE WE WE
WE DON'T CONTINUE DOWN THE ROAD --
TO TOO FAR BUT I THINK YOU'VE
MADE -- YOUR CASE -- TODAY AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
[inaudible]
MISTER COOPER. ONE THING THE
OFFERING THIS BILL FORD IT'S
IT'S MUCH WITHOUT ANOTHER FACT --
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT WE CLEAN UP
A LITTLE LABS LE METH LABS AND
DRUG LABS.
AND FOR THE SUPPORT PERSONNEL
THAT COME OUT AND HELP THEIR
ISSUE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE GEAR.
THEY HAVE THAT IS THE STANDARD
BY OSHA SO THERE'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE AND WE DO KNOW THESE --
CANCER CAUSING CARCINOGENS SAME
WORDS BUT IT'S UP NETWORKS
OBVIOUS THEIR SUPPORT STAFF IS A
IS A BIG PART OF ANY PUBLIC
SAFETY ENDEAVOR.
AND WILL MAKE SURE THEY'RE GIVEN
THE PROPER TRAINING AND
EQUIPMENT TO DO THEIR JOB AND I
DO BELIEVE I MEAN FIVE FIRST
COME BACK THERE CLOTHING IS LOST
THAT'S THEIR CONTRACT.
THE WATER TURNOUT GEAR.
SO IS THIS SOMETHING THAT'S MUCH
NEEDED AND AS WELL THANK YOU FOR
BEING A FORWARD THANK YOU THE
FIREFIGHTERS CERTAINLY CAN'T GO
OUT IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE
TRUCKS AND THE EQUIPMENT NEEDED
AND WE CERTAINLY WANT THEM OUT
ALL THE TIME.
PROTECTING US.
WELL SAID.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- S.
KAMAGRA DOES THANK YOU FOR
SUMMARIZING AND FOR A ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AND IF THERE ARE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS I THINK WE'LL GO AHEAD
VOTE WAS OUR MOTION AND A SECOND
ON THIS.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU LET'S GO AHEAD VOTE.
ON AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES.
MAYES I AM BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
CALDERON.
CALDERON I JAN.
CAN I CHIU. TWO I COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER I FRAZIER.
GIPSON.
GIPSON I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON ICON WATER DOES HI
KAMLAGER-DOVE I VOEPEL.
ALL RIGHT THAT PASSES A WITH TEN
VOTES.
A CLEAR MAJORITY THANK YOU MISS
KAMLAGER-DOVE MISTER ALLISON AS
WELL THANK YOU -- I THINK -- MS
GONZALEZ IS.
NEXT UP WITH TWO BILLS. TWO
BILLS.
ARE YOU GETTING ARE YOU GETTING
ANY SLEEP THESE DAYS -- YEP YEP
YEP.
SORRY YOU LOOK WELL RESTED SO.
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN I AM IF I CAN START
WITH AB ONE NINETY SIX PAID
FAMILY LEAVE I'M GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR.
I'M PROUD RE SENDING A WOMEN'S
CAUCUS PARTY BILL AB ONE NINETY
SIX WHICH WOULD ENSURE WORKERS
YOU SEEN -- CALIFORNIA'S PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM CAN RECIEVE
HUNT PERCENT WAGE REPLACEMENT
DURING THE PERIOD OF THEIR LEAVE.
THANK YOU -- THIS THIS REALLY
JUST SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT WOMEN
WHO -- IT IN PARTICULAR WOMEN
WHO ADD DON'T MAKE ENOUGH MONEY
I HAD TO LIVE ON 6270% OF THEIR
INCOME EVAN IN FACT WE KNOW THAT
THAT A MINIMUM WAGE WORKER
CANNOT LIVE ON 70% OR INCOME.
COULD ACTUALLY EXERCISE A RIGHT
TO PAID FAMILY LEAVE BY HAVING A
LARGER INCOME REPLACEMENT --
WITH THAT.
GO AHEAD THANK YOU.
I'M KINDA LIKE COLLISON NINE CO
CHAIR OF THE STATE -- LIFTING
CHILDREN FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY.
TASK FORCE AND THIS BILL WAS AN
URGENT PRIORITY OF THE TASK
FORCE -- IT'S A FOUNDATIONAL
ISSUE IN TERMS OF THE INFANTS
AND PERRANCE ABILITY. TO BOND
WITH ONE ANOTHER AND THAT'S
SIMPLY TAKES TIME.
AND WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT IS
MAKING SURE THAT LOWER INCOME.
WOMEN AND THEIR CHILDREN HAVE
THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES TO BOND.
AS UPPER INCOME CHILDREN.
AND LET LET ME JUST INDICATE AT
A COUPLE OF STATISTICS THAT SHOW
ITS IMPORTANCE. FOR LOWER INCOME
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
THE ABILITY TO UTILIZE FADE
HAMLEY LEAVE THE UTILIZATION
RATE IS 24%.
UP 232%.
IT'S THIRTY THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
RATHER IT'S 3000030% UTILIZATION.
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IT'S 41% UTILIZATION FOR THOSE
EARNING OVER SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS IT'S A 78% UTILIZATION.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT LOWER
INCOMEPEOPLE SIMPLY CANNOT TAKE
THE REDUCTION IN INCOME WITH THE
POVERTY LINE AT LEAST THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND HIGHER?
IN LOS ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO
IN THE OTHER.
URBAN URBAN COUNTIES.
OR WHAT THAT TRANSLATES INTO IF
LOWER INCOME PEOPLE WERE ABLE TO
TAKE PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
AT THE SAME PERCENTAGE AS UPPER
INCOME WOULD BE ANOTHER EIGHTY
THREE THOUSAND FAMILIES A YEAR.
WOULD BE ABLE TO UTILIZE IT.
SO OVER FIVE OR SIX YEARS WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
A HALF A MILLION FAMILIES BEING
ABLE TO UTILIZE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE SO THIS IS SIMPLE.
THIS IS SOLELY ABOUT LOWER
INCOME PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO BOND
WITH THEIR CHILDREN THE INFANTS
HAVING THOSE BENEFITS. TO THE
SAME EXTENT.
AS WEALTHIER FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU MISTER CALL
US.
PLEASE GO AHEAD BECAUSE IF YOU
THAT I MEAN IT'S NOT TO KNOW
WHAT CHILDREN NOW.
A CHILDREN'S EARLIEST BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT IS THE FOUNDATION OF
THEIR LIFELONG HEALTH AND
SUCCESS.
THE FIRST FEW YEARS OF LIFE
RABIES BRAINS. FOR MORE THAN ONE
MILLION NEURAL CONNECTIONS
RESEARCH ALSO MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT THOSE RELATIONSHIPS FEEL
THIS EARLY BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
POVERTY AND ON MATT BASIC NEEDS.
I MEAN FAMILIES CAN WEAKEN
DEVELOPING BRAIN ARCHITECTURE
BUT STABLE NURTURING
RELATIONSHIPS AND PARENT CHILD
INTERACTION CAN BUFFER THE
IMPACTS.
OF ADVERSITY AND FOSTER
RESILIENCY.
TING A VERY YOUNG CHILD PLACES
ENORMOUS PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL
DEMANDS ON ADULTS -- ESPECIALLY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA MANY
CONDITIONS AND CIRCUMSTANCES CAN
STAND IN THE WAY OF CHILDREN
GOING UP HEALTHY.
OUR CHILDREN NOW WITH PRESIDENT
TED LAMBERT WAS PART OF THE
LIFTING CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
OUT OF POVERTY TASK FORCE AND
WITH A MEMBER OF THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD SUBCOMMITTEE WHICH
RECOMMENDED.
INCREASING THE WAGE REPLACEMENT
21100% FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS WITH
THE GOAL OF INCREASING
UTILIZATION OF PAID LEAVE
POLICIES.
AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES
ALMOST A THIRD OF CALIFORNIA
WORKERS CLAIM THEY DID NOT MAKE
USE OF THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM.
DUE TO THE LIMITED WAGE
REPLACEMENT THIS IS A
DISPROPORTIONATE CONCERN. FOR
WOMEN OF COLOR WORKING LOW WAGE
JOBS WHO COULD NOT POPPED OUT OF
PAID WORK WHEN THEY'RE FACING
THE PRESSURES OF BEING THE
FAMILY SOLE PROVIDER.
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THAT WILL BETTER ENABLE ALL
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
MEET THEIR HEALTH AND FAMILY
NEEDS WITHOUT SACRIFICING THEIR
ECONOMIC SECURITY.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD SIR MY NAME
IS CURTIS CHAN I'VE BEEN A
MEDICAL DOCTOR IN CALIFORNIA FOR
ABOUT THE LAST TWENTY YEARS. FOR
SERVING AS A PEDIATRICIAN AT UC
SAN FRANCISCO AND CURRENTLY AS
DEPUTY HEALTH OFFICER FOR THE
FOR THE SUBSTANCE COULD
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
I'M HERE TO DESCRIBE WHY THIS IS
A BILL THAT'S A PRIORITY FOR
MANY HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS AND
MEDICAL OR ORGANIZATIONS.
AND CHILDREN'S ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA -- IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE IMPORTANT CHILD
DEVELOPMENT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
IMPACT ON BABIES AND CHILDREN.
THAT AFFECTS THE ENTIRE LIFE
COURSE AND NUMBER TWO IT HAS A
TREMENDOUS OF IMPACT ON MATERNAL
STRESS.
TOXIC STRESS AND MATERNAL
DEPRESSION AFFECTING MOTHERS AT
THE MOST CRITICAL STAGE OF LIFE.
SO I WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS AND THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE.
AND I JUST WANT TO DESCRIBE WHAT
WE'RE ACTUALLY SEEING IN OUR
CLINICS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A SIMPLE SCENARIO.
OF A MOM COMES INTO OUR CLINIC
AND SHE MAKES TWENTY DOLLARS AN
HOUR.
SHE'S FIRST TIME MOM.
AND NOW SHE HAS A LOT MORE BILLS
TO PAY [inaudible]
A CRIB [inaudible]
DIAPERS.
POTENTIALLY BABY FORMULA FOOD
SAVING UP FOR CHILDCARE BABY
EQUIPMENT SHE MAKES TWENTY
DOLLARS AN HOUR.
WHAT'S THE LIKELIHOOD THAT SHE'S
GOING TO TAKE MATERNITY LEAVE IF
HER PAY IS CUT. TO FOURTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR.
THAT'S THE DECISION THAT'S IN
FRONT OF US AS A STATE.
AND IT'S REALLY A DECISION FOR
US AS A STATE AS LEGISLATORS
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS EMPLOYERS
AND ELECT AND PEOPLE AND AND AND
RESIDENTS WERE VOTING.
ARE WE A STATE THAT WANTS TO
PROVIDE A BASIC OPPORTUNITY FOR
BABIES. TO BOND WITH THEIR
PARENTS FOR THE FIRST SIX TO
TWELVE WEEKS OF THEIR LIFE.
ARE WE GOING TO ENSURE THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
AND THE SECOND QUESTION IS ARE
WE GOING.
TO BE A STATE THE INSURERS A
BASIC RIGHT FOR BASIC BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT EARLY CHILDHOOD BAY
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
IN THE FIRST SIX TO TWELVE WEEKS
OF LIFE OR ARE WE GOING TO BE A
STATE.
THAT BASIC FINANCIALLY ALLOWS
BABIES TO BE SEPARATED FROM
THEIR PARENTS IN THE VERB VERY
FIRST FEW WEEKS OF LIFE.
THAT'S THE BASIC QUESTION ARE WE
ENOUGH OF A STATE DO WE HAVE
ENOUGH WEALTH IN OUR STATE TO BE
ABLE TO BE ABLE TO FOR THAT SO
THAT'S THE QUESTION THAT RIGHTS.
FOR US AS PEDIATRICIANS THE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY SIR.
OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR OR
FOR THE WITNESSES.
IF NOT -- MISS GONZALEZ YOU HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY -- TO SUMMARIZE --
I DIDN'T SEE ALL THOSE -- I
SHOULD WOULD USE MY GLASSES MORE
OFF.
OF ANY PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR THE BILL PLEASE GO.
FOR COME FOR WITH.
KEVIN ANTS GO FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
KATHERINE -- GONE ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
HI SUE BRING HIM WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSET BUILDING
COALITION AND ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN CENTER LONG POVERTY ONS
IN SUPPORT.
TAYLOR JACK SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING A HUNDRED THOUSAND
UNION NURSES STATEWIDE IN
SUPPORT.
RIGHT NOW SOME WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES A STRONG
SUPPORT.
JACQUELINE N. S. WITH A. R. P.
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY GONNA GONNA BE
HALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS A CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE
TRADES COUNCIL THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WHICH DUGGAR WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE HAVE A
SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION ON
THE BILL WHILE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE OUTCOME IN THE GOALS
AND EXPANDING PAID FAMILY LEAVE
WE JUST.
HOPE THAT IT LEADS TO A BROADER
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE FUND
PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND WHETHER IT
MAKES SENSE TO INCLUDE EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE PERSONS
WISHING TO SPEAK AGAINST THE
BILL.
THERE ARE NONE SO THIS IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO SUMMARIZE MISS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER THANK YOU -- I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT YOU
KNOW THE GOVERNOR HAS INTRODUCED.
MEASURES THAT.
WE CAN ALL SUPPORT TO EXTEND THE
TIME PERIOD THAT PEOPLE CAN STAY
HOME IT STARTED SIX MONTHS AND I
THINK THEY'RE GONNA SETTLE ON
EXTENDED BY TWO WEEKS.
BUT THOSE DISPARITIES OF WHO CAN
ACTUALLY STAY HOME.
DON'T GET FIXED FROM THAT SO
EIGHT WEEKS -- IF WE'RE SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE EIGHT WEEKS
OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE NOW WE'RE
STILL GONNA HAVE A VAST MAJORITY
OF OF LOW WAGE WORKERS WHO CAN'T
TAKE ANY TIME OFF.
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING BY JUST
SUPPORTING THAT FEATURE IS IS
MAKING THE DISPARITY EVEN WORSE.
AND SO MY CONCERN IS AS WE TALK
ABOUT LEAVE -- PAID FAMILY LEAVE
IN PARTICULAR THAT WE DO INSURE
THAT WE'RE NOT LEAVING PEOPLE
BEHIND AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN THIS BILL SEEKS TO
CORRECT THAT SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY GOOD.
THANK YOU FOR THAT EXCELLENT
SUMMARY OF THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS THIS
BILL ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER
CALDERON.
LOVE THE BILL LOVE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO WORK AT THE ONLY
QUESTION I ASK IS I I I I'M NOT
QUITE A WHERE YOU CAN IF YOU
COULD JUST ANSWER THIS REALLY
QUICK OF IN TERMS OF MAYBE
THEY'RE BEING UP.
IN INCOME CAP OF THERE'S NOT
ALREADY IN CONCERT THERE IS A
AND IT'S IT IS UP. TO SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND BASE OKAY DOLLARS SO.
MY WIFE IS ON LEAVE RIGHT NOW
SHE'S UNDER THAT.
BUT EVEN SO BECAUSE MY INCOME WE
ARE ABLE TO IT'S FINE LIKE IF IF
SHE HAD FULL IT WOULD BE NICE
BUT IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
NECESSARY SO JUST TO KEEP THAT
IN THE BACK YOUR MIND.
THAT WOULD THAT WAY WE BECAUSE
WE WANT THE BENEFITS TO GO TO
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE AT THE LOWER
END BECAUSE IT'S DIFFICULT ON
THEM BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT THEY
DON'T MAKE AS MUCH MONEY.
WHERE PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF I WILL
NECESSARY ALTHOUGH WOULD BE NICE
IT DOESN'T WE DON'T NECESSARILY
NEED HER TO BE A 100%?
RIGHT WELL BUT IF I AND I WOULD
JUST CHALLENGE A LITTLE BIT --
IF SHE WERE SINGLE MOM THOUGH IT
AND AT THAT LEVELSHE MIGHT NEED
A 100% AND I UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW
I'M.
OBVIOUSLY IF WE IF THIS IN
BUDGET WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHERE WE CAN
LAND ON THIS TO MAKE IT AS
WORTHWHILE -- BUT AS MAYBE
CONSIDER IF THAT'S A DIFF THAT
THE DUKE AND COME HOUSEHOLDS IN
LIKE THAT ANY OF THAT BUT RIGHT
NOW WEEK WE START THIS
DISCUSSION AT A 100%.
SO THAT WE COULD -- JUST
SHOWCASE THE DISPARITY IN A AND
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO TAKE ON
THE LOWEST WAGE WORKERS FIRST --
PHASE IT IN UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT
NOW I THINK THE GOVERNOR HAS
DECIDED HE IS GOING TO DO THE
DIGITAL TWO WEEKS AND NOT TAKE
ON THIS ISSUE AND SO I THINK
IT'S A POINT THAT THIS --
LEGISLATURE STATE THEIR OPINION
ON THIS FEATURE OF PAID FAMILY
LEAVE.
BRIDGET THAT MOVE THE BILL.
GOOD ACTORS RISEN MOTION AND
SECOND TO APPROVE THIS BILL ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
IF NOT AND AGAIN THANK YOU TO
THE WITNESSES WHO TOOK THE TIME
TO JOIN US AND TO CALL US SO YOU
SPENT SOME TIME HERE IN THIS
BUILDING OVER A IN THE PAST.
SO NICE TO SEE YOU BACK HERE --
IT'S TIME TO VOTE.
AB ONE NINETY SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS DALY
AYE DALY AYE MAYES.
MAYES I BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
CALDERON CALDERON I CHAN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CHU AYE COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
FRAZIER GIPSON.
GIPSON I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I COME LONGER DOES
[inaudible]
VOEPEL.
THE BILL HAS.
EIGHT ALL RIGHT -- THE MAJORITY
OF THE COMMITTEE HAS VOTED IN
FAVOR.
AND A SOME MEMBERS ARE MISSING
SO I'M SURE THEY'LL BE SOME
ADDITIONAL VOTES.
WE HAVE THREE FAILED THREE BILLS
LEFT -- MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER HAS
ONE REMAINING BILL AND THEN
MISTER CHIU AND MISTER GRAY.
AS WELL SO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AB -- TEN SIXTY SIX IS
THE BILL BE PRESENTING NEXT IN
AND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR EYES.
YOUR STAFF'S ANALYSIS AND WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES --
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS GOOD THE
BILL DETAIL.
THEN I SHOULD I SHOULD HIGHLIGHT
THIS BILL HAS THE THE CHAIR
SUPPORT AND I'M RECOMMENDING
APPROVAL OF THE BILL.
AND THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER FOR ACCEPTING THEM
MA'AM THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY AND
I'LL JUST POINT OUT THAT --
OTHER STATES IN FACT PROVIDE
POOR ODD LOCKED OUT AND STRIKING
WORKERS TO ACCESS UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS THIS WOULD ALLOW --
LOCKED OUT WORKERS OF COURSE AT
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS THEM AT THE REGULAR
TIME OF ANY UNEMPLOYED PERSON
AND WOULD ALLOW STRIKING WORKERS
AFTER -- BEING IN A LABOR
DISPUTE OF LONGER THAN -- WHAT
FOUR WEEKS BECAUSE AT THE THE
NORMAL ONE WEEK BUT AN
ADDITIONAL THREE WEEKS I'M TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS STRIKING AT THE
THE DECISION TO TO GO ON STRIKE
IS NEVER AN EASY -- ONE A IT IS
SELDOM THAT STRIKES LAST THAT
LONG IT IS THE ONLY IN THE MOST
EXTREME CASES AND UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE OF SO MANY FEDERAL
INTERFERENCE IS -- OUR LABOR
LAWS ARE OUT OF BALANCE IN THIS
WILL HELP -- AT LEAST KEEP --
STRIKING WORKERS FROM GOING
HUNGRY SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY VOTE [inaudible]
THIS IS.
GO AHEAD SIR.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN DALY --
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS TOM RUNYON VICE
PRESIDENT COMMUNICATION WORKERS
OF AMERICA DISTRICT NINE WHICH
COVERS CALIFORNIAN ABOUT AND WHY --
WE ARE CO SPONSORING AB TEN
SIXTY SIX UNDER CURRENT LAW
EMPLOYEES ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS IF THEY
LEFT WORK TO A DUE TO A TRADE
DISPUTE.
AB TEN SIXTY SIX WOULD RESTORE
ELIGIBILITY FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS AFTER THREE WEEKS HAVE
PASSED.
THIS IS SIMILAR TO A BILL
ADOPTED RECENTLY IN NEW JERSEY.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
COVER ONLY A FRACTION OF A
WORKER'S PAYCHECK.
AB TEN SIXTY SIX WILL HELP DETER
LARGE EMPLOYERS FROM USING
UNREASONABLE NEGOTIATING TACTICS
SIMPLY TO DRIVE WORKERS TO
FINANCIAL RUIN.
AB -- TEN SIXTY SIX ONLY.
COVERS A MODEST PAYMENT BUT NONE
THE LESS WOULD HELP WORKERS MAKE
ENDS MEET IF BARGAINING IS
PROLONGED.
THE BILL WILL CREEP EIGHT A MORE
LEVEL FIELD BETWEEN EMPLOYERS
AND EMPLOYEES OUR MEMBERS HAVE
WORK FOR THESE CORPORATIONS FOR
YEARS AND DESERVE ACCESS TO
THOSE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS.
THIS BILL IS EXCUSE ME CRUCIAL
TO MAKING SURE WE ARE TREATED
FAIRLY AND BOTH SIDES.
ARE.
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH.
I WANT.
TO TAKE THE TIME TO THANK
ASSEMBLY WOMAN LORENA GONZALEZ
FOR SUPPORTING AND SPONSORING AB
TEN SIXTY SIX I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
TODAY.
AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
MEASURE.
THANK YOU SIR.
GO AHEAD MITCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL -- ALONG WITH
C. TO BE WAY THE UFCW MAINLY TO
WE BELIEVE BETTER ALIGN OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEM
WITH ITS TWIN INTENDED PURPOSES
OF BOTH HELPING WORKERS SURVIVE
THE HARDSHIPS OF UNEMPLOYMENT
BUT ALSO HELPING THEIR
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES AND
LOCAL ECONOMIES DO THE SAME.
THAT WHEN A GROUP OF WORKERS
GOES OUT ON STRIKE AND THEY'RE
LEFT WITH NOTHING.
THEY CAN NO LONGER BUY GROCERIES
THEY CAN NO LONGER PAY THEIR
MORTGAGES AND THE NEGATIVE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF THAT CAN
SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITY
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS THAT WE DO HAVE AN
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEM IS
TO HELP.
MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF THINGS
LIKE THAT.
AND JUST TO OUR QUICKLY RESPOND
TO A FEW -- OPPONENT CONCERNS AS
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN STATED THERE
ARE A LOT OF BUILT IN
DISINCENTIVES THAT DISCOURAGE
WORKERS FROM STRIKING.
AND TO IMPLY THAT GIVING THEM
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
ESPECIALLY AFTER A MONTH WE
WOULD ARGUE PRETTY SEVERELY
MISUNDERSTANDS WHAT GOING ON
STRIKE IS ACTUALLY LIKE -- FOR
ONE THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SYSTEM ONLY REPLACES WAGES AT AN
AVERAGE OF 26%.
SO WHEN YOU GO OUT ON STRIKE
YOU'RE COLLECTING ON AVERAGE
ABOUT A QUARTER OF WHAT YOU WERE
EARNING SO WHEN YOU COUPLE THAT
WITH THE MONTH LONG WAIT -- THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT MOST OF US
WOULD REALLY STRUGGLE TO DO AND
SO WE THINK THAT ALONE -- WILL
ALWAYS MAKE SURE THAT WORKERS
WILL ONLY STRIKE AS THEY DO NOW
WHEN IT'S THE ABSOLUTE LAST
RESORT.
AND BEING ON STRIKE IS A
GRUELING HORRIBLE EXPERIENCE
IT'S NOT SITTING AT HOME WITH
YOUR FEET ON THE COFFEE TABLE
WITH SOME.
YOU'RE OUT PICKETING YOU'RE OUT
ORGANIZING USUALLY MUCH HARDER
THAN YOUR ACTUAL JOB AND SO THAT.
COMBINED WITH THE FACT THAT IT
CREATES A LOT OF BAD BLOOD IN
THE WORKPLACE IT'S NEVER REALLY
THE SAME AFTER THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING NO ONE WANTS TO DO.
AND THAT'S WHY I WAS ALSO
MENTION STRIKES ARE SO RARE. ONE
FEDERAL AGENCY THAT TRACKS VERY
LARGE STRIKES OF AFFECTING OVER
A THOUSAND WORKERS FOUND THAT
THERE WERE ONLY THREE IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS.
ANOTHER ONE THAT STRUCK THE
TRACKS SMALLER STRIKES FOUND
THAT FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN DEPENDING ON
HOW YOU COUNT THERE ARE ONLY
SEVEN TO TEN STRIKES THAT WOULD
BE A FACTORED BY THIS BILL.
ONLY AFFECTING A TOTAL OF ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE WORKERS.
TINY TINY FRACTION OF THE
OVERALL UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SYTEM SO WE THINK THE AFFECTS
THAT WOULD BE PRETTY MINIMAL.
AND JUST FINALLY -- THE
OPPONENTS ALSO REFERENCE THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA UFCW STRIKE
THAT WE THINK IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF WHY THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT. FOR ONE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF WORKERS AFFECTED
WERE LOCKED OUT.
SO WHETHER THEY WANTED TO WORK
OR NOT THE EMPLOYER WASN'T GONNA
LET THEM BUT BECAUSE OF SOME
QUIRKS AND ARE YOU WHY SYSTEM
THEY WEREN'T ALLOWED TO COLLECT
BENEFITS.
AND SO THE BILL FIXES THAT AND
ALSO FOR THE WORKERS WHO DID GO
OUT ON STRIKE THE EMPLOYER LONG
STORY SHORT BASICALLY WANTED TO
GET RID OF THEIR ENTIRE HEALTH
PLAN AND THEIR PENSION PLAN.
SO THESE ARE WORKERS WHO WERE
REALLY BACKED INTO A CORNER
WHERE THEY WERE FACED WITH THE
LOSS OF HEALTH CARE AND THE LOSS
OF RETIREMENT SECURITY.
AND SO THEY ALSO WERE DENIED YOU
AYE BENEFITS AND THAT'S WE THINK
YOU KNOW REALLY THE KIND OF
SITUATION WHERE WORKERS.
HAVE NO OTHER OPTION THERE
REALLY FORCED TO TAKE THIS NO
MATTER WHAT THE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCE OF GOING ON A STRIKE
MIGHT BE.
THOSE ARE EXACTLY THE KINDS
WORKERS THAT WE THINK ARE OUT
THERE THAT SHOULD BE ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS BILL BUT
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO LOSE
EVERYTHING AS A RESULT OF TRYING
TO DEFEND WHAT THEY'VE GOT WE
ARE TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER SEMEN.
OF OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
OF UNITE HERE THE TEAMSTERS THE
IN THE BOATMAN'S UNION -- THE
MACHINISTS AND OTHERS ALL IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
JAZZY GIRL WITH UFCW WESTERN
STATES COMES ON STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LIZ SORENSON COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT NINE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND I ASSUME WE ASSUME YOU'RE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OF ALL THE
OTHER FOLKS WITH THE RED SHIRTS
TODAY YEAH [inaudible]
RIGHT HERE.
AND THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENDANCE.
WE APPRECIATE IT [inaudible]
AND WE APPRECIATE THE THE
DECORUM AS WELL IT'S VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
ANY PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK
AGAINST THE BILL I SEE A COUPLE.
HEARTY SOULS HERE [inaudible]
THE WELL WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE GO AHEAD -- GOOD
MORNING -- MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE ROBERT MUTRIE -- FOR
THE CAL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE --
AND WE ARE OPPOSED AB -- TEN
SIXTY SIX FIRST AYE I WANT -- TO
BRING OUT YOU KNOW WHAT WE ARE
WHAT OUR OFFICE IS NOT BASED ON
OUR VISION IS NOT BASED ON THE
IDEA PROVIDING -- BENEFITS
GENERALLY TO INDIVIDUALS ON
STRIKE.
IN SITUATIONS WHERE THEY ARE.
SHORT ON ON FOOD YOU KNOW THESE
DESPERATE SITUATIONS TALKED
ABOUT IF THE STATE WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE BENEFITS IN MID IN MANY
WAYS THE STATE DOES AND CAN.
THE ISSUE OF ON OUR AND IS THIS
CHANGES THE BASICALLY THE
PURPOSE OF THE UNEMPLOYMENT
SYSTEM WHICH UNTIL NOW WAS SET
UP AS A BALANCED INCENTIVE
INCENTIVIZING EMPLOYERS. TO
ENSURE STABILITY IN THE
WORKPLACE BY NOT TERMINATING
EMPLOYEES WITHOUT REASON AND AND
KEEP IN PLACE ON AND SERVE AS
EMPLOYEES TO IF THEY ARE
TERMINATE THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN. TO HELP THEM
TRANSITION THAT WAS THAT THE
BALANCE OF INCENTIVE SET UP IN
THAT BALANCE IS REFLECTED IN THE
FUNDING SYSTEM FOR YOU WHY --
YOU KNOW IT.
AS I'M SURE THE COMMITTEES WHERE
YOU AYE IS FUNDED INTO TEARS THE
FIRST YEAR FOCUSED ON THE
INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYERS CONDUCT AN
EXPERIENCE RATING IN THE SECOND
HERE FOLKS ON THE OVERALL HEALTH
OF THE FUND -- AND TAKING THOSE
ONE BY.
ONE I'M FIRST LOOKING TO THE
INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYER -- IN THESE
SITUATIONS LET'S SAY THAT.
AS A LABOR DISPUTE PROGRESSES
AND AGAIN WE WE ALSO HOPE THAT
LABOR STREETS ARE NOT NEEDED.
IDEALLY ALL OF THESE CAN
YOURSELF EARLIER YOU KNOW
ABSOLUTELY -- BUT IN THE EVENT A
LABOR DISPUTE DOES PROCEED AND
WE REACH A POINT WHERE THIS
BILLS NOW A FOUR WEEK THRESHOLD --
KICKS IN -- WE'RE LOOKING AT AN
EMPLOYER THE INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYER
INVOLVED FACING INCREASE THEIR
EXPERIENCING RATING FOR LET'S
SAY YOU KNOW A HUNDRED TWO
HUNDRED YOU KNOW WHATEVER THE
SIZE THE UNION BUT X..
INCREASE BASED NUMBER EMPLOYEES
INVOLVED -- AND THAT SIGNIFICANT
THE INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYER GOING
FORWARD FOR SOME TIME BUT EVEN
STEPPING BACK TO THE BROADER
QUESTION ABOUT THE FUNDS OVERALL
HEALTH.
I'M INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYERS YOU
KNOW THE FACE THAT AND EVEN IF
WE ASSUME MOMENTARILY INDIVIDUAL
EMPLOYERS ARE CAUSING ISSUES.
THE ENTIRE FUNDS SUSTAINABILITY
IS AN ISSUE HERE AS AS YOU ALL
ARE AWARE RECENTLY THE FUN WAS
DEEPLY IN DEBT.
AND THE STABILITY THE FUN COMING
OUT OF THIS BILL IS A CONCERN ON
OUR END.
FRIEDMAN EMPLOYERS WHO DO NOT
HAVE STRIKES AND DO NOT -- TURN
ON ALL OF THESE SITUATIONS SO
BECAUSE OF THE SOURCE OF THESE
AND AND PULLING UNEMPLOYMENT BY
THE WAY INTO AN AREA WHERE.
TRADITIONALLY IT IS IS NOT WAY
IN LABOR DISPUTES IT'S NOT
INTENDED THAT WAY IN FACT THERE
IT AS LAW THAT.
EDT IN INVESTIGATIONS EVEN IF
THE FACT THE TERM IN THAT.
WHICH WAY THE DISPUTE WAS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT SUPPOSED
INFLUENCE BENEFITS SO -- BY
POLITICIZING YOU AYE AND ALSO
BECAUSE OF THE COST ADDITIONS TO
NOT JUST EMPLOYERS INVOLVED IN
STRIKES INTENSELY ALL EMPLOYERS
A WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU SIR MS RICE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU.
NICOLE RISE CALIFORNIA MANY
FACTORS IN TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE ALSO
OPPOSED TO THE BILL FOR THE
REASONS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
STATED -- JUST WANT TO ADD ALSO
RELATED TO THE HEALTH OF THE
FUNDS SO -- EMPLOYERS JUST TO
ENCOURAGE A TEN BILLION DOLLAR.
PAYMENTS TO FOR THE U. I FIND
WHEN WE WERE IN THE RECESSION
AND THE FUN WENT INSOLVENT AND
WE HAD TO PAY THAT BACK BECAUSE
OF THE LOAN THAT WE TOOK OUT
FROM THE FAT.
THAT WAS OUR RESPONSIBILITY BUT
WE ARE BUT OUR CONCERN ABOUT
THIS BILL IS NOW A POPULATION OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT IS OUTSIDE OF
THE REACH CURRENTLY OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ARE NOT PERMANENTLY
SEPARATED FROM THEIR EMPLOYMENT
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
WILL NOW HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
RESOURCES AND THE QUESTION THAT
WE ASK THE COMMITTEE IS TO
CONSIDER HOW THAT WILL IMPACT?
THE THE SOLVENCY IN THE HEALTH
OF THE FIND PARTICULARLY SENSE
WE ARE HEARING MORE AND MORE
EVERY DAY ABOUT.
BEING CLOSER AND CLOSER OR
EXTENDED OVER FROM WHERE A
RECESSION WOULD HEAD SO WE THINK
THAT THOSE CONSIDERATIONS AS
WELL AS THE ONES THAT WERE
MENTIONED ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE
RATING AND HOW THAT WILL IMPACT
OUR EXPERIENCE YOU RATING AS
EMPLOYERS.
AND THE FULL NATURE OF THE FIND
OUR REASONS -- FOR OUR
OPPOSITION AND WE ASK FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER THAT AND
TO YOU WE QUIT AND WE REQUEST A
NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS RICE -- ARE THERE
OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK
AGAINST THE BILL.
IF NOT COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
THE BILL. FOR ANY OF THE
WITNESSES OR FOR THE AUTHOR.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION IS A SUPPORT
POSITION -- IT'S A VERY THOUGHT
PROVOKING SUBJECT AND I THINK
IT'S BEEN HASHED OUT PRETTY
THOROUGHLY -- OUR OF OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF DID A GREAT JOB
ANALYZING IT AND THERE ARE SOME
UNKNOWNS GOING FORWARD BUT WE
WILL SEE WHAT THE EXPERIENCE
ACTUALLY IS -- THE FUND IS HAD
TO SOME TO SOME TOUGH TIMES AND
IT'S SO IT'S SOLVENT NOW AND
IT'S IN BETTER SHAPE THAN IT'S
BEEN IN MANY YEARS THE RATES
HAVE COME DOWN.
OF IN SOME CASES SO WE'LL SEE
WHAT THE EXPERIENCE IS.
BUT I THINK -- THERE ARE MANY
THINGS TO LIKE IN EMBRACE ABOUT
THIS BILL IN AGAIN -- I'M
RECOMMENDING SUPPORT POSITION IS
OUR MOTION AND SECOND.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND SECOND
MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS THANK YOU I
WOULD JUST SUGGEST -- IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE HOW WE VIEW
DE POLITICIZING SOMETHING I
GUESS COMES FROM THE POINT OF OF
OF YOUR ACTION I THINK THIS
ACTUALLY DE POLITICIZE IS THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND.
BECAUSE WHEN SOMEBODY IS OUT OF
WORK -- OFF AND AND AND I THINK
IT WAS STATED AT NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN THEY STILL NEED TO PAY
THE BILLS AND OUR ENTIRE
COMMUNITY SUFFERS WHEN --
WORKERS HAVE TO TAKE THE VERY
EXTRAORDINARY STEP OF GOING ON
STRIKE AND LET'S BE HONEST FOR
OVER FOUR WEEKS.
HAVING -- WALKED PICKET LINES
WITH WORKERS WHO WHO WERE STUCK
IN THAT POSITION I CAN I CAN
TELL YOU THE PERSONAL HARDSHIP
THAT THAT THEY AND THEIR
FAMILIES HAVE TO SUSTAIN AND
IT'S ALWAYS.
A A IF THE STRIKE GOES ON THAT
THAT LONG IT IS ALWAYS BECAUSE
THEY ARE STRIKING FOR THEIR VERY
LIVELIHOOD -- AND I THINK THAT
THE PRESSURE ON EMPLOYERS TO
SETTLE DISPUTES WILL GROW -- AND
THAT'S PROBABLY A GOOD THING
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT'S ALWAYS
THE PRESSURE THE INDIVIDUALIZED
PRESSURE ON THE WORKER TO GIVE
IN IN A DISPUTE AND I THINK AN
ENTIRE COMMUNITY ALL THESE
BUSINESSES WILL BE AFFECTED BY
THE EMPLOYMENT -- INSURANCE FUND
WOULD BE WOULD ALSO THEN UP AT
IT BE ABLE TO HAVE HONEST
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE EMPLOYER AS
WELL I THINK THAT THAT ADDS TO
MORE BALANCE IN IN THE PROVISION.
I WILL ALSO STATE THAT -- WE
HAVE BEEN SITTING ON THIS BILL
FOR IT SINCE I WAS ELECTED
HONESTLY -- AND THAT IS BECAUSE
IN OUR TALKS WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE NET DE WE REALIZE THAT
THE FUND WAS IN A BAD POSITION
BUT WE ARE NO LONGER IN A BAD
POSITION AND SO -- WE HAVE
WAITED UNTIL WE ARE IN A
POSITION OF OF HEALTH AND
STRENGTH WITH OUR FIND IN ORDER
TO MOVE THIS BOARD AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
ALRIGHT SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND
VOTE THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND.
ON A. B. TEN SIXTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
CALDERON.
CALDERON I CHEN [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHU AYE COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
COOPER [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
GIPSON.
ABSENT I GRAYSON [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL NO [inaudible] SEVEN ONE
SO THAT'S A SEVEN TO ONE VOTE
THERE'S SOME OF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO WILL BE RETURNING
AND NOW THEY WILL WILL ADD THEIR
VOTES ON THANK YOU [inaudible]
AND I THINK MISTER GRAY IS NEXT
UP IF USED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
WHEN A LITTLE LONGER THAN WE
THOUGHT TODAY?
MR GRAY IS HERE.
ON A. B..
TWELVE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD MR GRAY THANK YOU.
HEY MITCH CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS -- I'LL KEEP THIS RATHER
BRIEF.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT.
AT LEAST OVER THE COURSE THE
SEVEN YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE WITH
THE CHAIRMAN -- AND OTHERS WE'VE
SEEN MULTIPLE MATERNITY BILLS
COME.
BEFORE MANY OF OUR COMMITTEES.
AND AMONGST ALL THOSE MATURITY
BILLS.
IT APPARENTLY DIDN'T OCCUR TO
ANYBODY.
THAT YOU CAN GET PREGNANT TWICE.
WITHIN TWELVE MONTHS.
AS THE OPPORTUNITY CAN PRESENT
ITSELF WHERE YOU MIGHT NEED TO
TAKE LEAVE.
TWICE IN A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD
THIS.
CAME TO MY ATTENTION -- ACTUALLY
THROUGH THE PREGNANCY OF A STAFF
MEMBER OF MINE WHO EXPERIENCED
THIS ISSUE AND FOUND THEMSELVES
IN A SITUATION.
WHERE THEY NEEDED?
TO TAKE LEAVE.
IT DURING THAT TWELVE MONTH
PERIOD WAS ABLE TO SO.
I'VE BEEN REDUCED TO A
RELATIVELY SIMPLE BILL THAT
ADDRESSES THAT ISSUE AND
AUTHORIZES -- THAT LEAVES.
AND WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR AYE
VOTE CONSIDERATION -- HERE THIS.
MORNING [inaudible]
GOOD.
I ALREADY MISS GERMAN I THANK
YOU FOR THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
WHICH I'VE TAKEN WHICH HAS ALSO --
REMOVED ALL THE OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE THAT YOU SEE IN THE
ANALYSIS BEFORE YOU MEMBERS
RIGHT AND THANK YOU FOR A THE
THE CONSTRUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS --
TO THE TO PUT THE BILL IN THE
BEST POSSIBLE SHAPE. FOR FOR THE
NEXT STEPS.
AS WE HAVE DISCUSSED ANY PERSONS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THIS BILL.
HERE'S ONE RAIN SPENCER WITH THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STATURE NINE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR ANY OTHER PERSONS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN FAVOR.
ANY PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK
AGAINST THIS BILL.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON THE BILL.
IS THERE A MOTION AND SECOND
MISTER BERMAN HAS QUESTION QUICK
QUICK QUICK COMMENT -- MY WIFE
AND HER SISTER WERE BOTH BORN
WITHIN TWELVE MONTHS I THINK ANY
MOM THAT THAT DOES THAT DESERVES
PAID LEAVE AND AND THE HUGE
METAL -- THAT SO THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW THERE'D BE THE BERMAN
YOU COULD CALL THIS THE BERMAN
BILL ARMAND ASSANTE YEAH YEAH
OKAY OKAY YEAH OKAY MY MY WIFE.
ALL THE CREDIT THEIR MOM FOR
THIS AT THE RIGHT TIME TO BRING
BACK TO STARTING TO OUR A
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL.
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND TO
PASS THIS BILL ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISS COM
LAGER DOVE [inaudible]
HALF.
VERY COMMON FOR HE CAN SAY MY
WHAT I DO YEAH I DO A LOT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR PICKING UP ON
THAT THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
I THINK WE KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT RIGHT YEAH.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
DISCUSSION IF NOT LET'S GO AHEAD
VOTE [inaudible]
SECOND [inaudible]
THE SECOND.
ON A. B. TWELVE TWENTY FOUR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DALY AYE DALY I'D
MAY.
MAYES I'D BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CALDERON CAULDRON AYE
CHEN.
CHEN AYE.
TO CHU AYE COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
COOPER [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
GIPSON.
GIPSON I GRAYSON.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I'D [inaudible] ELEVEN
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
MEMBERS YOU BETCHA THANK YOU.
THE LAST VOTER THE LAST BILL OF
THE DAY -- FOR THIS HEARING IS
MR CHOOSE BILL.
MR CHOOSE BILL IS.
AB [inaudible]
ELEVEN OH SEVEN ITEM.
SEVEN COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
CHEERING AND YOU HAVEN'T EVEN
STARTED TO SPEAK YET.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TIME ALSO WITH HIM FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VEAS.
HOPING THAT. TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
IT BECAUSE SHE ALSO WANTED.
TO SOME COMMON.
BUT THIS WILL SERVE AS AN
ONGOING DISCUSSION WAS THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON WAYS TO ENSURE
TIMELY PROCESSING OF WORKMAN'S
COMPENSATION CLAIMS.
I BROUGHT THIS BILL FORWARD DUE
TO A CONCERN THAT MANY MEDICAL
TREATMENTS ARE BEING DELAYED
THROUGH TO WORKERS COMP AS
COMPENSATION PROCESSES.
I LIKE TO EXPLORE WAYS TO CREATE
MORE EFFICIENCY WHEN ANGEL
WORKERS CAN GET NECESSARY
TREATMENT AND GET BACK TO WORK
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
IT IS A OF BENEFICIAL FOR THEM.
THE EMPLOYEES AND THE FLORENCE.
THE OF A COMPANIES THANK YOU.
TODAY THEN I HAVE A STEP THAT
THE COMEDIANS SUCH A SUGGESTION.
THAT THE BILL WOULD BE NARAL AND
THAT IS -- WOULD BE A VEHICLE
FOR THE STAKEHOLDER DISCUSSION
ON THE DELIVERY MEDICAL CARE TO
INJURE WORKERS IN A MORE
EFFICIENT MANNER.
I'M COMMITTED TO BRINGING THIS
BILL BACK TO TO COME MEDIA AFTER
DEATH STAKEHOLDERS PROCESSES.
HAVE OCCURRED AT A WALL SO WANT
TO THING ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIAS BE
COME IN.
AND JOIN US TO ADD A COMMENT
[inaudible]
GOOD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU.
GO AHEAD MS REYES TURN MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL.
I AM A CO AUTHOR OF AB ELEVEN OH
SEVEN AND FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT TO
GIVE SOME CONTEXT TO THE ISSUES
RAISED BY THIS LEGISLATION.
AS SOMEONE WHO IS PRACTICED IN
WORKERS COMPENSATION FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS BEFORE COMING
TO THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
AS THE ANALYSIS MENTIONS.
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO
FACILITATE A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
TO REVEAL WHAT APPROACHES WHAT
APPROACHES WE CAN TAKE.
TO IMPROVE MEDICAL CARE AND THE
WORKERS COMP SYSTEM.
AS SOMEONE WHO SPENT HER CAREER
REPRESENTING INJURED WORKERS I
CAN TELL YOU THAT IN SPITE OF
THE BEST EFFORTS OF OUR FORMER
GOVERNOR AND MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE.
THE SYSTEM WE HAVE IN PLACE NOW
CREATES AN ADVERSARIAL
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE PARTIES
INVOLVED.
EVEN WHEN THEY MAY AGREE ON A
COURSE OF TREATMENT.
WHILE THE EXISTING SYSTEM WAS
DESIGNED TO SAVE MONEY FOR
BUSINESSES TO BETTER RATES AND
REDUCE COST I WAS DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE TIMELY TREATMENT.
WE HAVE SEEN THE LADIES IN
PROVIDING MEDICAL TREATMENT FOR
VERIFIED AND DIAGNOSED WORK
RELATED INJURIES.
CALIFORNIA IS NEAR THE BOTTOM
AND TIMELY TREATMENT COMPARED TO
OTHER STATES.
AND COSTS TO EMPLOYERS REMAINS
HIGH.
THESE DELAYS HURT BOTH EMPLOYERS
AND WORKERS.
BUT WHENEVER THE IDEAS DISCUSSED
TO REFORM UTILIZATION REVIEW AT
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW
PROCESSES.
WE FIND THAT REASONABLE
DISCUSSIONS ARE PUSHED ASIDE.
BY THE FALSE IDEA THAT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM WORKS.
AND IS SO SACROSANCT THAT THE
THOUGHT OF CHANGING IT IS
POLITICAL HERESY.
TODAY I OFFER TO YOU THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE TO DISCUSS THESE ISSUES.
WITHIN THE CONFINES OF PREVIOUS
CONFLICTS.
IT'S OKAY TO ADMIT THAT WE NEED
TO IMPLEMENT CHANGES TO THE
SYSTEM THEY WILL GET WORKERS THE
TREATMENT THEY NEED WITHOUT
DELAY.
AT THE SAME TIME KEEP COSTS DOWN
FOR BUSINESSES.
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON SUCH AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR PRESENTING THIS
BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU MISSED REYES AND YOU
HAVE SOME WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE.
THANK YOU -- GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY I'M DIANE WORLEY
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APPLICANTS ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION.
I WANT TO ALSO THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS CHIU ANDREAS FOR
INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE AND THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR YOUR
ONGOING WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
WHILE THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
REFORM BILLS ENACTED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN HAVE RESULTED IN INCREASED
PERMANENT DISABILITY BENEFITS
FOR WORKERS AND LOWER INSURANCE
COSTS TO EMPLOYERS THEY HAVE
ALSO GENERATED RECORD PROFITS
FOR INSURANCE CARRIERS.
HOWEVER THE COST OF THESE
REFORMS HAVE BEEN UNACCEPTABLE
TREATMENT DELAYS FOR INJURED
WORKERS.
A NATIONAL STUDY FROM THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION RESEARCH
INSTITUTE RELEASED LAST YEAR.
COMPARED DELAYS AND
AUTHORIZATION FOR MEDICAL
TREATMENT ON WORKERS INJURY
CLAIMS IN EIGHTEEN STATES IN
THIS STUDY CALIFORNIA CAME IN
DEAD LAST. FOR EVERYTHING EXCEPT
FOR THE INITIAL MEDICAL BILLS
THAT.
THIS STUDY CLEARLY DEMONSTRATES
THAT CALIFORNIA'S INJURED
WORKERS FACE LONG DELAYS IN
RECEIVING TREATMENT.
COSTING EMPLOYERS AND LOST TIME
AND COSTING EMPLOYEE EMPLOYEES
IN LOST EARNINGS.
CALL RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON AB ELEVEN OH SEVEN AS
THE BEGINNING OF THE DISCUSSION
NOT THE END TO FIND A WAY THAT
GREATER EFFICIENCY.
MIGHT BE BUILT INTO THE MEDICAL
REVIEW PROCESS AND REDUCE THESE
UNACCEPTABLE DELAYS.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTIE BELL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIRES FIREFIGHTERS
ALSO PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND I CAN SAY AS A
PERSON WHO SAT AT THE TABLE
DURING THE LAST.
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT REFORMING THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM I
THINK OUR AUTHOR AND CO AUTHOR
SAID IT PERFECTLY -- THAT WAS AN
EFFORT AND IT IS NOW YIELDED
MORE ISSUES FOR THIS LEGISLATURE
TO DEAL WITH MY MEMBERS ARE NOT
SATISFIED MY MEMBERS ARE AWFUL
WORK MUCH LONGER THEY INTEND TO
BE.
BECAUSE THEY'RE WAITING WELL
THIS ADVERSARIAL IN FRICTIONAL
SYSTEM DEBATES OVER WHETHER THE
TREATMENT THEIR PHYSICIAN
RECOMMENDS IS ACTUALLY.
GOING TO BE DELIVERED IN THE
MEANTIME IT'S COSTING EVERYONE
MONEY AND IT'S COSTING US IT'S
IT'S PUTTING IN A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF PRESSURE ON MY MEMBERS
WHO JUST WANT TO GO BACK TO WORK.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE AT HOME.
SO THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR -- FOR MOVING THIS
BILL FORWARD TODAY AND FOR TO
OUR AUTHORS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION TO MY MEMBERS.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
EXCUSE ME I'VE LEARNED JUDGES SO
I KEEP UNEVEN OFF MY VOICE
PROJECTS VERY WELL TODAY.
IT WILL HIT WHAT CHAIR THANK YOU
THANK YOU GO GO HEAD -- SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL MISTER
CHAIRMAN SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
EFFORT WORRY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY
OTHER PERSONS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
IF NOT OTHER PERSONS OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL [inaudible]
AND WELCOME GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME FLOOR CURTIS AND I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY THIS MORNING WE DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES --
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL I THEY
DID A GREAT DEAL WITH THEM
REMEDIATING SOME OF OUR PROBLEMS
HOWEVER WE HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO
FULLY ANALYZE THE FULL SCOPE OF
WHAT THE IMPLICATIONS OF THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE WOULD DO.
OUR CONCERN AT FIRST GLANCE IS
THAT IT POTENTIALLY PUTS THE
OPINIONS OF THE COURT ABOVE THE
OPINIONS OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TO ANALYZE.
THE I AM OUR PROCESS AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ARE STILL
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THIS TIME
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS STATE
FOR JUST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY IS.
WE ALSOAPPRECIATE THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS THAT REMOVE VERY
TROUBLING LANGUAGE AND ARE STILL
REVIEWING THE RECENTLY AMENDED.
TAX TO THE BELL BUT WE DO HAVE
SOME INITIAL CONCERNS AND JUST
WANTED TO I BRING FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION IF YOU
POINTS ON INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
RUBIO.
THE CALIFORNIA WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSTITUTE RECENTLY
REPORTED THAT NINE OUT OF TEN
YOU ARE DENIALS ARE UPHELD.
AND IT'S THE TOP 1% OF DOCTORS
THAT ACCOUNT FOR FORTY FOUR
POINT 2% OF DISPUTED SERVICES WE
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT 95% OF
LETTERS THAT REQUEST I ADMIRE IN
RESPONSE TO INJURED WORKERS
REPRESENTATIVES ALMOST ALL OF
THEM ATTORNEYS.
AND THAT'S WHAT REQUIRES CLAIMS
ADMINISTRATOR STAFF TO SPEND
TIME CONTINUALLY RESPONDING TO
THOSE FILINGSRATHER THAN ON
SPENDING THEIR TIME PROVIDING
TIMELY AND ACCURATE BENEFITS TO
INJURED WORKERS WHICH IS OUR
MAIN OBJECTIVE.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHER PERSONS WISHING
TO OPPOSE THE BILL MARK SEVEN
WITH THE AMERICAN PROPERTY
CASUALLY INSURANCE ASSOCIATION
AMERICA ALSO POST.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
MAKAYLA ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CLAIMS
PROFESSIONALS ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THE CALL RISE CALVARY
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO POST.
SHERMAN MEMBERS JOHN NORWOOD ON
BEHALF OF ZENITH INSURANCE
COMPANY LIBERTY MUTUAL WE SURE
OF THE CONCERNS ARE EXPRESSED
HERE AS WELL ON THIS BLL THANK
YOU.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO OBSERVE.
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY.
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
OR FOR THE CO AUTHOR.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
FRAZIER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS A FORMER
EMPLOYER I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
AND AS AN EMPLOYEE THE PROCESS
OF OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING.
TO ACCOMPLISHMENT AGAIN THERE
ARE -- EMPLOYEES ARE SENT TO
DOCTORS TO REFUTE THE INJURIES --
AND IT AND AND IT DOES DELAY
COMPENSATION IT STOPS
COMPENSATION AT SOME POINTS IN
TIME.
AND I DO LIKE THE THE PROCESS OF
OF THE 25% OR TEN THOUSAND
WHICHEVER WHICHEVER IS LESS.
I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
DETERRENT IN PLACE.
BUT IT'S TALK ABOUT HAVING A
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE GOING
FORWARD THIS BILL ISN'T A
PANACEA.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
AS FAR AS TALKING TO THE
OPPOSITION.
ABOUT FINDING A BALANCE BECAUSE
NOT ALL NOT ALL.
CARRIERS DO THIS AND SO WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE IDENTIFYING
SOME THAT DO.
IT'S NOT ACROSS THE BOARD --
TYPICALLY.
SO HOW DO WE GET TO YES ON A
BALANCE.
THAT BOTH OF BOTH OF THE
OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT CAN COME
TO A CONCLUSION THAT YES OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME THIS HAS BEEN.
A PROBLEMATIC [inaudible]
BUT WE WANT.
SOME KIND OF POLICY IN PLACE
THAT SAYS YOU KNOW WHAT WE WANT
WE WANT TO PREVENT FRAUD.
AND MAKE SURE THAT PREMIUMS CAN
STAY LOWER YOU KNOW AT A AT A
RATE BUT ALSO -- SO WHAT ARE YOU
DOING I MEAN WHERE YOU AT THE
LIST OF THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION YOU KNOW AND AT ALL
WITH YOUR CHALLENGE TO TO REACH
THAT BALANCE -- A BALANCE MEANS
AND AND NEITHER SIDE IS HAPPY.
AND I'M I'M.
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE WORKING ON
IT AND I WILL COME ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS THE OPPOSITION OF
AS WELL AND TO TO JOIN THE
DISCUSSION AND I WOULD
DEFINITELY.
WOULD INCLUDE YOU TO OF A JUST
JOIN THE DISCUSSION WILL -- WERE
IT IT IT IT IS -- UP HILL BATTLE
BUT YOU KNOW WE'LL BE WORKING ON
IT I KNOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REASSESS WILL BE WORKING ON THIS
FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
AND IF THAT'S NOT A USED TO WORK
BUT WORLD.
I FIGURES WERE TRYING.
I THINK IF I MAY OUT ALSO THE
BRINGING THE EMPLOYERS TO THE
TABLE IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT BENEFITED
FROM THIS REFORM EITHER.
THEIR RATES ARE STILL HIGH ADD
TO TREATMENT IS STILL BEING
DENIED AND STILL BEING DELAYED
AND THAT WE KNOW THAT TO ONCE
UTILIZATION REVIEW DENIES THE
BENEFIT.
AT THE I AM ALL I AM ARE --
LEVEL JUST AS WAS NOTED EARLIER
IT'S ALMOST ALWAYS TONIGHT.
SO IF YOU HAVE A TREATING
DOCTORS SAYING THIS TREATMENT IS
NECESSARY.
AND YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WHO'S
NEVER EXAMINED THAT EMPLOYEE NOW
COMING AND SAYING WE'VE REVIEWED
THE RECORDS NEVER TOUCH THAT
EMPLOYEE NEVER SPOKEN WITH
EMPLOYEE WITH THAT TREATMENT IS
NOT NECESSARY.
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG WITH
THAT DISCONNECT WHEN YOU HAVE AN
I AM OUR DOCTOR ABSOLUTELY
DENYING A BENEFIT AFTER REVIEW.
AND THAT THE IDENTITY OF THE I
AM OUR DOCTOR WILL NEVER BE
DISCLOSED UNDER LAW.
THAT DOCTOR CAN NEVER BE DEPOSED
UNDER LAW WE HAVE A SERIOUS
PROBLEM WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF IT AT THE DOCTOR
EMPLOYER.
EMPLOYEE LEVEL AND I THINK BRING
IN THE EMPLOYERS TO THE TABLE
pIS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THIS IS
TOO BIG AN ISSUE FOR ONE SIDE TO
TO COME FORWARD WITH WITH.
THE ONLY THE ONLY SOLUTION BUT
THE SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE WE
HAVE TOO MANY EMPLOYEES WITH
[inaudible]
LEGITIMATE ACCEPTED INJURIES
WHERE THE DOCTORS ARE
RECOMMENDING TREATMENT AND THE
TREATMENT IS BEING DELAYED AND
DELAYED WHEN YOU DELAY SOMETHING
THAT LONG YOU ARE DENYING THE
BENEFITS.
YOU ALL HEARD ME LAST YEAR THE
YEAR BEFORE WHEN I HAD THE THE
EMPLOYEES WERE FROM THE FROM THE
TERRORIST ATTACK IN SANDRA DINO.
WITH LEGITIMATE ACCEPTED THE
INJURIES WHO HAD ASKED FOR
TREATMENT DOCTORS TREATING
DOCTOR SELECTED BY THE EMPLOYER
HAD RECOMMENDED TREATMENT AND
YET THE TREATMENT WAS DENIED.
THERE IS A PROBLEM WITH THE
SYSTEM WHEN THAT IS ALLOWED TO
HAPPEN.
EMPLOYERS NEED TO BE AT THE
TABLE CARRIERS NEED TO BE AT THE
TABLE IN THE THE INJURED WORKERS
ALSO NEED TO BE AT THE TABLE.
YEAH AND I'D LIKE TO IF YOU CAN
SUPPLY TO ME THE DATA THAT
SUBSTANTIATES.
THAT HOW MANY TREATED WORKERS
HAVE BEEN DENIED WITH THE THE
VOLUME OF PEOPLE ON CLAIMS RIGHT
SO WHAT'S WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
NUMBERS WHAT'S THE DATE AT THE
DRIVE SINCE I'D LOVE TO SEE THAT
OKAY.
THE DATA IS AVAILABLE AND I
WOULD I THINK THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN IN THIS ANALYSIS WERE IN
YOUR PRESENTATION SAYING THAT
YOU KNOW 25% WORKERS HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE I AM OUR PROCESS.
OR WHATEVER THE SUBSTANTIATES
THIS IS GOING FORWARD.
I WAS EMPLOYED FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
I NEVER HAD A WORKMAN'S COMP
CLAIM BUT MY PREMIUMS WERE JUST.
I REGISTER.
SERIOUSLY WAS A BIG PART OF MY
OVERHEAD -- AND THANK GOD I HAD
IN CASE.
SOMEBODY WAS HER ON THE PROJECT.
OF THAT I WAS ON BUT YOU KNOW
THE THE THE FOLKS LIKE.
MIKE IN MY WORLD THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THE CLAIMS ARE PAYING FOR
THE FRAUD.
AND AND I DO WANT.
ALL OF THE FRAUD.
BEING TAKEN CARE OF YOU KNOW
POST HASTE -- BUT I REALLY WANT
TO SEE A DIALOGUE WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE TABLE.
SO SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
CONSTRUCTIVE JUST LIKE YOU AND
I'VE DONE WITH.
IN THE PAST -- SOME REMEMBER
THAT WE ACTUALLY GET GOOD DATA
THAT DRIVES THIS AND THEN MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY STAKEHOLDER CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE -- THEIR POINT OF
VIEW.
ARE BROUGHT INTO THE SENATE AND
AGAIN IT'S AN ANALYSIS YOU WANNA
HAVE THAT THAT UPPER APORTES
FEEDBACK GOING FOR NAY
APPRECIATE THAT SO THE BOOK FOR
TWO OF A GOOD DISCUSSION ALL
RIGHT SO WITH THIS BILL THERE
WILL BE AMPLE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE SHARING OF DATA AND FOR MANY.
DISCUSSIONS AND AND IT'S A IT'S
A BUT NINE BILL IN THE SENSE
THAT IT ENCOURAGES CONVERSATIONS
IN A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE EXPECT WILL
HAPPEN AND WILL AS MR CHIU TO
KEEP US INFORMED AND MS RACES
WELL KEEP US INFORMED OF THE
PROGRESS OF THE CONVERSATIONS --
THERE WAS A BIG REFORM IN THE
SYSTEM -- MY THINKING GOVERNOR
BROWN'S FIRST YEAR OR SOMEWHERE
IN HIS FIRST TERM AND SO WERE --
THERE'S LOTS OF DATA NOW AS TO
THE BOTH THE GOOD AND THE BAD
THAT HAVE RESULTED FROM THAT
MAJOR REFORM.
THIS BILL WILL A STIMULATE SOME
VERY.
HOPEFULLY SOME HELP HELPFUL
CONVERSATIONS AND SHARING OF
DATA.
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND ON
THE BILL.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
LET'S VOTE.
ON A. B. ELEVEN OH SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS DALY AYE DALY
AYE MAYES.
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW [inaudible]
CALDERON.
CALDERON I CHEN. TWO AYE CHU AYE
COOLEY.
I COOPER.
COOPER I FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I GIPSON.
ABSENT AYE GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON
AYE COM WATER DOT.
COM OCCURRED OF ICE.
VOEPEL [inaudible]
YES.
THE BILL HAS FOUND THAT THAT
BILL PASSES WITH TEN AFFIRMATIVE
VOTES THANK YOU MS REYES AND MR
CHIU.
SO WE WILL ADD ON NOW
OPPORTUNITY FOR ADD ONS
[inaudible]
YES.
START WITH CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE.
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CHEN.
CAN I COOLEY HI COOLEY I
FOURTEEN IS THERE A VOTE
[inaudible]
GREAT.
OKAY THEN AB. ONE NINE SIX
BERMAN [inaudible]
AND BERMAN AYE BIGELOW
[inaudible]
FREIGHT [inaudible]
COOPER.
COOPER I FRAZIER NO.
FRAZIER NO [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
LONGER THE AYE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL I TWELVE TO ONE ITEM
NUMBER. EIGHTY THREE FORTY SIX
COOPER [inaudible]
BERMAN.
OKAY -- COOPER VOTED TWICE A
YEAR VOTE DOESN'T COUNT
[inaudible]
AT BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CHEN OF ALL THE CHEN I
COOPER.
COOPER I THE BILL HAS FOURTEEN
ZERO VOTES.
A.. SEVEN FORTY BURKE
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE.
BIGELOW [inaudible]
CHANCE.
COOLEY HI COOLEY I MEMBERS THIS
IS AB SEVEN FORTY BY BURKE.
TWELVE THERE ARE. TWELVE TO ZERO
WITH A COUPLE OF STANCHIONS.
AB TEN SIXTY SIX GONZALEZ
[inaudible]
COOPER.
HI COOPER I FRAZIER NO FRAZIER
NO [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible] EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY TWO WITH A COUPLE OF
STANCHIONS.
ALL RIGHT.
AB [inaudible] ELEVEN OH SEVEN
TO MAYES.
TEND.
TO ZERO AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR
GRAY [inaudible]
COOPER.
COOPER I FRAZIER GREAT.
CRAZY FRAZIER HI GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE THE BILL HAS.
FOURTEEN TO ZERO A. B.. FOURTEEN
HUNDRED KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HI THE BILL HAS
[inaudible]
FOURTEEN ZERO NUMBER.
FOURTEEN AB SIXTEEN OH TWO ROW.
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW [inaudible]
HELLO NOW [inaudible]
IT CHEN.
CHEN NO.
COOLEY NO COOLEY NOW. 824- THIS
IS MISTER LOW'S BILL AB. SIXTEEN
OH TWO EIGHT TWO FOUR WITH A
COUPLE OF STANCHIONS.
HAS EVERYONE HAD A CHANCE TO ADD
ON I THINK SO.
I THINK WE GOT EVERYONE.
ALL RIGHT.
IF THAT IS THE CASE AS TRACY
INFORMS US EVERYONE'S VOTED ON
EVERY BILL -- SO THE HEARING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU